planning meeting 12th of august 2020
the referrals meeting is made up of
members from
both committees committees a and b
my name is cathy guthrie and i'm the
chairman today
may i first of all remind you of some
domestic arrangements
please ensure that microphones are muted
when you are not speaking
that you do not interrupt the other
speaker members are reminded
not to use the messaging chat function
during the meeting
unless it is to report a pecuniary
non-pecuniary interest
or to notify the chair that they wish to
make a proposal
members are reminded that they should
not have alternative communication lines
open
i.e other skype chats and that if you're
contacted by a third party during an
application
you should bring this to the legal
advisor's attention
that if you are attending the meeting to
speak and persistently
interrupt the meeting you may be asked
to leave
additionally you will be invited to
speak and ask questions by the chair of
the meeting
please await your turn we will not be
using the hands up function
except for declarations of interest site
visit requests
and declarations of lobbying if you are
experiencing poor connection issues and
that might well be an issue today
in the first instance please turn off
your camera
if this does not work please turn off
all incoming video
these options are under the three dots
on the main information bar
may i ask everybody who's not speaking
now to turn off their video for the
moment please
we are experiencing difficulties with
our computers so if you could turn off
your video
if you're not speaking i would like to
remind everyone present that this
meeting will be broadcast live to the
internet
and will be capable of repeated viewing
the whole of the meeting will be
recorded
except where there are confidential or
exempt items
if you make a representation to the
meeting you will be deemed by the
council to have consented to being
recorded
by entering this meeting as a speaker
you are also consenting to being
recorded by the council
and the possible use of those sound
recordings for webcasting and training
purposes
the council members of the public and
press may record
film photograph or broadcast this
meeting when the public and press are
not
are not lawfully excluded
introductions into prey legal advisor
robert carmichael governance officer
philip isbell chief planning officer
vincent pierce case officer stephen
stroud
strategic projects and delivery manager
and we have the ward members keith
wellum
and harry richardson christine thurlow
may also be present later on and she is
the professional lead for key sites on
infrastructure
and just before i move to the agenda can
we please just
acknowledge the fact that julie abby
taylor who's strategic housing teams
manager
has been with mid-suffolk district
council for the last 12 years
and she'll be leaving at the end of this
month and although she couldn't make
this meeting i think it should be
recorded that we would like to record
our thanks for all her hard work to mid
suffolk
and wish her well in the future
can i move to the agenda please
apologies for absence and substitutions
i will now ask the governance officer to
roll call
thank you chair um if it's a if it's a
visa that we don't have any further
connections i'll just do it by voice
thank you so if you could please respond
with present or good afternoon
so we have counselor james carsten
president
councillor rachel present council john
field
president council's peter gould
president
councillor kathy guthrie president
council lavina hattingham
president councilman matthew hicks
present
counselor barry humphries present
counselor sarah mansell
present councillor john matheson
councillor andrew mellon present
councillor richard mayer president
council dave muller
present council mike norris president
councillor andrew stringer president
councillor andrew
sorry casa roland warboys president
and council of welling
president and councilor richardson as
well
brilliant thank you chair we are all
present thank you to receive
declarations of pecuniary and
non-pecuniary interest my members
are there any and if you use the hands
up function in this i can see if there
is anybody
councillor maya um not sure it's
relevant but my daughter has her
wedding reception booked at columbine
hall which is linked to
gender item 8a
thank you for that and let's just just
come in madam sure i don't that that's
can be properly declared that's a
non-pecuniary interest it's not it
doesn't
affect the council's ability to continue
but it's it's been declared thank you
thank you and there was one other person
mike norris yes item 8b
thank you and what was it
pecuniary or non-pecuniary please i was
a
non-patron uh no sorry i got the wrong
item on the agenda because
i'm getting ahead of myself don't worry
it's the heat don't worry
sorry i thought we were on lobbying okay
i'm just having issues my
system is coming and going actually at
the moment i i think we will all
afternoon can you take your hand down
now
so that we can see who else is there
else for pecuniary or non-binary right
okay we move on
and declarations of lobbying and
yes i think there's going to be quite a
few others um
i think i'll put my hand into the bar as
well so i think that is all of us and i
think that would be right to say that it
would be the thirst and
application i've received an email of
lobbying would that be correct if
there's anything different
can you um make that known to me please
several emails of lobbying right
but for the for the thetford
yeah for the third yes sorry i told you
actually thurston yeah
um robert do you want to go through
everybody and ask them specifically
because there's so many hands going up
should we ask them individually can you
go through them please
yes sure i'll just go through them and
then if everybody put their hands down
and we'll come through to you all sorry
about that
so councillor carsten i thank you yes um
first an application for an email thank
you
councillor ebern the same thank you 8b
on the agenda cancer field
yes 8b several emails counselor called
yeah eight b uh several emails thank you
councillor guthrie yes eightly i've only
had one email actually
don't like me counselor hattingham
um 8b yeah thurston two emails
councillor hicks 8b council humphreys
hp councillor mansell
8b councillor madison
yes also ap yes thank you
councillor mellon yes eight b several
emails
councillor mayor 8b just the one
councillor muller 8b several emails
castle norris eight b also several
emails
caster stringer uh hb several emails
and council award boys
can you all take your hands down now
please we've gone through that thank you
yeah sorry i'm sorry we didn't hear from
council of war boys their chair
did we not i thought we did did we i'd
i thought i didn't hear anything i just
oh again
sorry i was a bit quick mutant um yeah
ap
thank you chancellor stringer can you
take your hand down please
thank you right
so that's lobbying declarations of
personal site visits
and if there's a multitude then i think
we'll go through them again
but
[Music]
so i've just got councillor mansell
uh yes i i happened to be
adjacent to the site for 8b uh earlier
this week
i've also i think i better declare that
i have visited the site
in stowapland a few months ago i was uh
exploring the footpaths and doing a bit
of mapping
uh for an orienteering event uh in
around the
location of the stoapland site so i
better declare that as a site visit
that's very good of you thank you very
much councillor matheson
councillor matheson
no microphone on yes i
i have was um looking at the site
last saturday in thurston yes thank you
and who is the one other is counselor
malin please
uh yes same visited the site in thurston
thank you thank you
can you take your hands down please
confirmation of the minutes of the
meeting held on the 29th of january
are there any points regarding accuracy
to the minutes please
and accuracy only thank you
there don't appear to be any so can i
have a proposal in a second
that i can accept the minutes of the
meeting please
councillor mansell's proposing and
councillor hadingham seconding
thank you very much everybody thank you
for your help there
um would you take a roll call please um
robert
thank you chair so if members could
please respond with
fought against or abstain
so council james carsten or
council rachel ebern four
counts to john field four
casa peter gould
council kathy guthrie four castle
lavinia hattingham
matthew hicks four that's the barry
humphreys
accounts to sarah mansell four
councillor john matheson
[Music]
dave miller four
count mike norris
counselor andrew stringer paul and
castle of all boys
four thank you chad that is carried
thank you the minutes of the meeting
have been confirmed and i will sign at
the next practicable
opportunity so we also have the minutes
of the meeting held on the 21st of
february 2020
and again are there any points regarding
accuracy of the minutes
and can i have a proposal and a second
to please
councillor muller and councillor
hadingham yep
happy to propose thank you and again
rob um robert if you can just run
through the members please
thank you chair so if you could please
respond with four against or abstain as
previously so councillor carsten
sorry councillor rachel burn or
councillor john field or castle peter
gould
poor councillor kathy guthrie oh
castlevania hattingham oh councilman
matthew hicks
for councillor barry humphreys paul
council sarah mansell epstein
councillor john matheson four
classes andrew mellon abstain
counselor richard mayer
councillor dave muller for
cancer mike norris abstain
that's andrew stringer
[Music]
and castle road and war boys
thank you chair that is carried and
again the minutes have been confirmed
and will be signed at the next
practicable opportunity
to receive notification of petitions in
accordance with the council's petition
scheme
then receive chair and the schedule of
planning applications will be as we have
them in the papers
which is we will start with the stow
upland and move on to the first and one
second
so i would now ask the case officer
vincent pierce
uh to introduce the application of dc20
01435 land to the south of gipping road
stow upland stone market
so if you would like to present your
case please thank you
thank you chair good afternoon members
and anyone who might be
listening i've just got to share my
screen
so hopefully that won't take a second
while you're doing that for the benefit
of the public um when um
the officers have made their
presentation uh members
are able to ask questions and they are
sync questions for clarity i'm sure um
and when anybody else is speaking they
will have three minutes
and the same thing applies there if
there's a question for clarity
we will ask the members to ask those
questions
i was just filling in for you vince
thank you very much i'm just
gonna ask whether you can actually see
anything
yeah can you see one image or can you
see
several images down the left-hand side
well i can see one image and then
several down the left-hand side
okay let's see there we go
has that now become one image correct
excellent well i can start thank you
everyone
this is a new application involves land
to the south of gipping road
in st upland it is an outline
application
and it is for up to 80 dwellings
there are a rich number of issues that
we need to look out they are explored in
detail in the report
but amongst the key planning issues
i would suggest we need to look
carefully at connectivity
landscape impact status of the current
plan the stow
upland neighborhood development plan
our five-year housing land supply
traffic sustainability
residential immunity and then at the end
i will ask members to weigh up
benefits and impacts in terms of a
planning balance
i do need to say that this presentation
is
here to supplement the detail in the
report
and all the representations that you may
hear later
during discussion
i'd just like to point out that stow
upland parish council
did provide an updated comment that
wasn't in your
report on the 13th of july and they
are maintaining their objection to the
proposal
and they're making a particular point
about the nature of the controlled
crossing
in church road and i'll go into that in
a bit more detail when we come to that
section of the
presentation but i've set their comments
up in full
on the screen at the moment so
first thing is stow upland is a key
service center
and as you all know a key service centre
is one of those locations where you
would expect the
majority of new development including
residential to be located along with
towns within the district
i've shown the application site in red
on the screen and we'll just put that
into context in a moment
that is a illustrative
master plan you won't see any housing
layout on that
that is because it's an outline
application
i do need to refer to the previous
scheme that members looked at in
january and refused that was a different
scheme
as i say this is a new application but i
will at times reflect back on to the
january
application and the decision because
there are areas that
both have in common the big difference
here is that the application now rather
than being for 70
dwellings or up to 70 it's now up to 80
dwellings
and there have been a number of layout
changes and i will describe those in
detail
as we go there is a copy of the previous
refusal that is in the
report
again just to prove that the
previous reasons refusal as members had
asked were actually the ones that were
issued
so i'm sure the question that springs to
mind on all members
tongues is so what are the differences
between this scheme and the one that you
looked at
back in january first thing is there
have been
layout changes to increase the depth of
landscaping
particularly along gipping road that was
an area that members had a lot of
concern over and also
the northern edge of threadstone's
meadow
we now have an inclusion of a controlled
crossing on
church road that wasn't previously
included in the scheme
we have a 50 000 pound financial
contribution towards improvements to the
a1120 and the b1115 junction
and or cycle route improvements
in stow upland we've also now secured
footwear improvements on church
church road so
in terms of the context what you have on
the screen at the moment
identified as trinity meadows is the
blue
homes development that's currently under
construction and that adjoins the
application site so in black you'll see
threadstones meadow in the foreground
and the site on the right hand side
disappearing into the distance you have
stow upland which merges into stone
market
in the far distance so the point i'm
making here is that
the application site is already adjoined
by
new development
there is threadstone's meadow of which
more later
that's a shot of blower homes just to
give you a flavor of
the development or the character of
development you have already approved
we do need to go through a quick resume
of policy because this is a new
application
stopland does have an adopted
neighborhood plan and that dates from
2019.
the application site is shown with a
yellow star
i don't know whether my cursor shows in
this location
here so that's the blue home site that's
under construction
and that's the application site
if we take a look at the stow upland
neighborhood development plan in terms
of
allocations when you add up the
sites and existing permissions that are
referred to in that document
we get a figure of 349 dwellings
so the plan does make provision for that
number of
of units
and there is that list that gives us the
the number
i referred to three four nine in the
previous slide because
we have added on the extra 19 that were
agreed as an uplift to the
blue development you'll see here that
the actual stir up the neighbor plant
says 331
i also draw your attention to the note
at the bottom of that table within the
neighborhood plan that says
it will be reviewed on an annual basis
again another slide so as you can see
from the screen
within the neighborhood plan the site
sits outside of the settlement boundary
so the red line is the settlement
boundary
the air in green is threadstone's meadow
and in the plan that is identified as a
local green space
and i just refer you here to the green
gap which is another designation
in the neighborhood plan south
of church road and again this is the
blue site
which is included within the settlement
boundary
just that's the application site which
does include threadstones meadow
still upland i've just plotted some of
the
key facilities within the village and i
think that probably is in the background
papers
as well i now turn to the baba
mid-suffolk
joint local plan and on this screen
you'll see in blue that's the
blue site the application site
within the jlp is actually
allocated for residential development
and is within the settlement boundary
now i have to say that the joint local
plan at the moment has
limited weight but it is an expression
of
direction of travel of the council in
terms of accommodating the significant
uh growth that we have to secure in the
period up to 2036.
so this site is known in the jlp as
la-079
is actually allocated for 100 dwellings
so when we look at the allocations
against the joint
local plan the identified requirement
set by the council in its
draft joint local plan is 752 dwellings
so between the 752 and the figure i
mentioned earlier within the
neighborhood plan
the 349 figure there is a deficit
and there i've just explained
the nature of that deficit on or around
200 and sorry 421 dwellings
or 402 after you've deducted the 19 from
blue
and the table on the right again from
the grp just
shows you how many communities are being
asked to accommodate
substantial numbers of new dwellings so
elmswell at eight three four i at
five four one still upland at seven
five two thurston fourteen hundred and
sixty eight
and we'll pitch 727
again just to remind everyone that the
starting point for
discussion is our
development plan our adopted development
plan
in terms of constraints what we have
sorry if we go back to that we have a
literally building up here which is
columbine hall
and there's a scattering of listed
buildings down here on church road
obviously the site sitting in here but
you'll notice
the site sits right at the hub of a
complex network of public footpaths and
they run through
threadstone's meadow and here we have
the edge of the
settlement boundary within the existing
adopted local plan
in terms of the site and particularly
threadstone's meadow which you can see
in this image so you can actually see
the paths that are cutting across and
there's obviously
i assume that's dog walkers a circular
route
around threadstone's meadow but it's
worth saying that it isn't
in an area of outstanding natural beauty
it isn't a triple si
site of special scientific interest it
isn't a local nature reserve it isn't in
a special landscape
area there are no protected trees on the
site and so on
although as i say it is identified in
the neighborhood plan
as a local green space
just to show you how complex the network
of
public footpaths are in and around stone
upland
i've never seen as many of that in any
other settlement so
it's quite remarkable in terms of access
whilst access would be a reserve matter
what is being proposed on the
illustrative layout is for the vehicle
access to come in from
the adjacent blue homes development
the green triangle at the top is the
access
for emergency vehicles that would not
as shown on this plan be the main
access to the development and obviously
this estate
already has a purpose built access onto
church road
that shows in a bit more details yet
coming off church road through the
estate the
under construction and into the
development site
just to give you a better idea of how
they connect
so here's a shot from gipping road
looking south towards
church road and you can start to see how
that footpath network
takes you in all directions from
threadstone's meadow
one of the key footpaths runs adjacent
to
the blur homes trinity meadows
development so here's a
quick trot along that route you'll see
the development on the right
application site will come into view
shortly so there we are at the
gap in the hedge we're entering into
threadstones meadow
there's a pond already in there that
would be safeguarded so you get a feel
hopefully let's just make sure
a quick shot round
this is the site that would actually
be gifted for a pound where members to
approve
the development and this is this
is the bit in the um neighborhood plan
that is identified as a
local green space
and again
this is from the application site
moving from threadstone's meadow across
the hedge and now we're looking into the
development side and you'll see
trinity meadows development to your left
we're now looking towards gipping road
and just on the right is the hedgerow
beyond which would be
remain farmland
and then that takes us out onto
gipping road
that's looking back towards thurston
from gipping road
so in terms of i
apologize stop upland in terms of
connectivity here we have the sighting
in green
this is what i this is the built up
parts of stow upland
right in the center of that is the high
school
and you'll notice broadly speaking as
the crow flies
the site is approximately 600 meters
from
the center of that target as is
much of the existing built up parts of
stow upland but clearly that is just as
the crow
crew flies we will come back and look at
some more detail
this is from the school the high schools
website and you can see that they are
actively advocating uh students to
arrive
from a number of different locations
so the school itself can is permeable
from
the west the north the east i guess
you'd say that was the
the south west and i'll show how this
development links into some or all of
those
so in terms of connectivity if you were
to walk from
the center of the development site
using the estate road on trinity measure
meadows
and pop out onto church road you'd be
approximately
three quarters of a mile from the high
school
however if you were to cut across
the new adjacent development and along
the public footpath
you'd be significantly less but the
moment i can't actually quite see what
that is because i've got a picture of
you chair
right as that but i don't know whether
you can actually see that but that's
significantly less that is
easy walking distance
and again if you wanted to walk to the
co-op
it's about a mile from the heart of the
development side but of course if you
cut through threadstone's meadow
through here you would reduce the
journey time
again a lot of connectivity in all
directions
feature of the latest proposal is a
controlled crossing
on the a1120 in opposite
or near to the co-op so this is the
co-op and the service station in here
in this location would be ins
would be installed controlled crossing
now
i think in the report i've referred to
it as a toucan and what my
colleagues in highways have advised me
is that the type
would be appropriate for that location
so
if cycle facilities can be improved to
that point
it could be a toucan if they can't
then it would be one of the others it
might be a puffin which is
geared towards pedestrian activity
but it would be a controlled crossing
and i think i do need to draw that
point out because quite rightly i think
councillor william has pointed out that
a toucan would only be applicable where
you could cycle using cycle lanes
to get to that point but the big
difference is between this and the one
in january and a number of members said
well how do people get from this
development to the co-op
safely this is the way that you would
get to the co-op
safely because it would involve stopping
traffic and allowing
at least pedestrians to cross and the
number of members reported last time
that
during lunch breaks and at the end of
school a lot of pupils from the high
school
actually gravitate towards the co-op to
um
presumably to get sweets or snacks or
or whatever another shot
so here is the co-op the a120 this is
um thorny green the pavement at that
point
is just over three meters wide but there
are pinch points in here and there is a
verge
yes you can just about see this path
that swings right the way down here past
the 1120 the 1115 junction
that's potentially where some of the 50
000 pounds could be spent
improving cycle connectivity
just to illustrate the difference
between a puffin and the toucan
also that money could be used to improve
this junction as i say and how that
could be achieved would be
by widening the carriageway on the
east side here taking away some of the
existing verge
enough to allow you to create a widened
lane so you get a protected right turn
and that is something that has been
advocated locally to try and
get that resolved and what uh gladman
have said is that
they would fund that work
up to the 50 000 limit
set by suffolk county council as being
what is required to achieve that
improvement so again that wasn't
in the proposal back in january
also included you remember i referred to
footway improvements on
church road in this shot you'll see the
village hall and you'll notice this bit
of verge in here
what's being proposed is that any bits
of urge like that within the highway
would actually be given a hard surface
treatment
and again that effectively increases the
width of the
existing footwear and makes it more
navigable
for users of the path and again that
deals with a number of pinch points that
were pointed out to us at
the last meeting in in january and again
that would be funded by
the admins were permissioned to be
granted
also a point that came up last time in
january was
it was suggested that you cannot you get
to
the co-op using a complete
continuous footpath that may well have
been true in
january or at the end of last year but
since trinity med
meadows has really taken off there have
been
fantastic new footways put in at the
northern end
so you can actually now go from beyond
trinity meadows
all the way down into the heart of
stone upland on a continuous footpath
so again in terms of connectivity that
issue has been
resolved simply through the actions of
trinity meadow has been implemented
this diagram shows the various routes
that people can take to get around the
village it is a
permeable village some of those are
public footpaths so obviously they're
there some of them are adjacent to trees
some of them are adjacent to hedgerows
but there is an extensive network
and of course with the improvements to
church road you now have a
well-drained hard surface corridor
to get from the application site into
the heart of the village
so there's one route to the school
where you can actually go along church
road and down to the car
now threadstone's meadow i think you'll
recall from last time that the parish
council
are opposed to the development they
don't want any more residential
development
however securing threadstone's meadow
into public ownership is acknowledged
as a benefit
now what i need to point out here is
that last time there was
a committee in on this slide there was
quite a bit of concern expressed about
how close the edge of this development
along here was to this northern boundary
of
threadstone's meadow and it was felt
that that encroachment of urban form
would actually be a threat to the
character of threadstone's meadow
so what we have done is we've negotiated
a reduced footprint for the development
site
and the deeper buffer so just where that
green area has come up
you can actually see that that lime
green color represents the additional
open space
that is now included that wasn't
available in
in january so we have listened and so
have
the applicants to members concerned in
that respect
in terms of buffer depth we have got on
the eastern margin
at least a 20 meter buffer you may
recall chair and members there was a
an expression of concern about the depth
of this buffer on the northern edge
because as you rightly recall columbine
hall the listed building was what was
over here
this has now been increased
to 30 meters that has been
sufficient to encourage our
heritage officer to change
the professional view expressed in
january to now
to uh very low less than substantial
harm on the heritage asset that
columbine hall and again now at the
south
you've you've got a a 54
meter deep buffer before you get to the
northern edge of
threadstone's meadow that's 177 feet
just to explain the difference on
gipping road
this shot at the top is the current
proposal and the one at the bottom is
the one that you
saw in january so effectively
there's been an increase in the buffer
as shown in lime green here
that was the scheme that you looked at
in january and you'll notice
this edge of the development and its
proximity to this
boundary so here we have threadstone's
meadow
with the increase in open space and
planting what has actually happened is
effectively
you get that so this could be
heavily planted that's the matter for
later discussion at reserve matters but
that is a significant
setback when you think how close this
development is to the boundary that used
to exist
and again up on gipping road
up here effectively what's happened is
that boundary has increased too so in
that sort of illustrative form we can
demonstrate
a significant enhancement to landscape
buffering
in terms of impacts on views and
landscape
a critical area to consider
again not an iomb not a special
landscape area
it isn't identified as a key view in the
snow upland neighborhood plan and i've
set that out in the
report and it isn't in the green gap
identified in the stowatland
neighborhood plan however threadstone's
meadow
is a local green space
and that wouldn't be touched by
development
were this to be approved
so the site is identified within the
suffolk landscape character assessment
as ancient
plateau clay lands and what i've tried
to do here is
show you the extent of that character of
landscape
so here we go whole of stone market
still upland in here so everything i've
shown in brownies
ancient plateau clay lands and the
reason for that is that you obviously
have
a series of rivers and
streams that feed the river running up
so effectively what you have is
a valley that yellow bit represents a
valley so the
slopes the valleys slope up and then
gradually flatten off
and that is just dictated by the pattern
of rivers and streams in the
the area so as you go through you end up
with the valley meadow
lands adjacent to the river you start
gently moving up the slope of the valley
you get to the ancient plateau clay
lands
and in the very top of that plateau the
fact that it's clay lands is because the
soil is largely
clay
a quick shot of trying to put that all
into
context obviously here we have stone
market
and we're gonna hopefully fly
towards stow upland
we're just coming up to junction 50 and
crossing the a14
and we swing around
we move towards still upland
and there we have the site hoves into
view that's the trinity meadows
development and there is the application
site
and what you have around all of that is
effectively farmland with the occasional
house and dotted settlement
another flight will move from walnut
tree farm
which is a large complex of buildings to
the
northeast of the site you've got gipping
road in
just interview on the right that field
would not be developed
you move into the application site with
threadstones meadow on your left
trinity meadows under construction and
then as we
zoom out you'll see urban stone upland
the high school thorny green
more urban stopland which gradually just
morphs into
stone market
i just want to explore this uh the
nature of views within the
neighborhood plan because this shows it
quite clearly
the blue squares identify
important key views and the direction of
this sort of fan shaped
arrangement is telling you the direction
of that key view
so here's the application site so that
view is looking away to the north
that view is looking away to the north
that view is looking away to the east
what you do get in this and it's
acknowledged in labour plans
are views of built up
stow upland which makes sense
particularly when you think that this
site
will soon be fully developed for housing
and that's the blue homes trinity
meadows
so technically it isn't identified as
the key view
in stowe upland's own neighbourhood plan
neither is it included in the important
green gap to
saxon street which sits on the south
side of
church road so the area just to the
north which would include the
application site
has not been identified as green gap
that opportunity was not taken in the
neighborhood plan
other green gaps have been identified in
the neighborhood plan
as shown in the uh the green arrows
place services in a comment on the 7th
of august
commented on a number of
elements of the scheme and what they
have said and confirmed
is that they have no objection provided
that
the mitigation measures identified are
implemented
they acknowledge that the increase to
the buffer to the
north of threadstone's meadow and on
keeping road
have made an important difference
so in terms of the landscape obviously
we are going to be looking and they are
looking to have a traditional indigenous
species
hedge trees and hedge woodland so
let's take for example an english oak
which uh the woodland trust identifies
the
ruling majesty of the woods and we would
certainly expect to see
oak included in the planting regime here
because there are a number of
fine oaks in the area an oak takes
about a year to grow half a meter
so oaks planted on this site
after 10 years would be six meters high
and after 15 years would be eight meters
high
that's if they're planted as whips but
what we have here is a
a picture from barcham's the
nursery and other nurseries are
available
but you'll notice that you can buy these
oaks semi-mature so they're already five
meters high
what we've done on other sites is we've
inter
interspersed with planting with
semi-mature planting so that you get
instant impact but over a longer period
the whips catch up and become
a much thicker uh screen
and i have to say it is quite clear and
we fully acknowledge that in year one of
this development in times of planting
it would be far more visible
than in year 15 so we're not trying to
conceal the
the truth about it will make an impact
on the landscape
however the enhanced landscaping will by
year 15
have a much softer impact
and it will blend into the into the
distance because the trees will then be
in the foreground
so there is this initial period whilst
the planting gets established
but don't forget we've already got the
established hedgerow around
threadstone's meadow so it won't be as
stark as perhaps i'm
i'm alluding to
as an example i know of this site in
elmsday market in
in essex this area up here was field
and between 2008 and i've actually got
2102 but that should be
2020 so that's 2008 to 2012.
they've become transposed
trees were planted as whips in this area
that is a shot
very recent shot so within
seven to or so a bit more
certainly 12 years that is how dense
that planting has become
and that's the sort of thing i have in
my own mind that we'd have that sort of
blanket
planting to really create that deep
landscape
buffer and as i say that's a mixture of
whips
and larger trees
heritage impacts i have gone into into
those in some
detail and i just
redraw your attention to the heritage
offices very low than this of potential
harm the increased buffer on
gibbing road has made a significant
difference there we have columbine hall
a very fine
moted uh house grade two staff so we
need to be very careful we need to be
sure that
it won't have an impact adverse impact
on that
setting and if we do think it has an
impact we then have to
under paragraph 196 of the mppf
weigh the public benefits against that
harm
so here is columbine hall here is the
blue homes development
in this area we have recently approved
individual houses
here's the application site here's an
existing
buffer of trees and over here we have
existing bungalows and of course that's
the walnut tree farm
so our our argument here is that
with this recent development with these
existing trees and now the deeper buffer
the impact of this on the setting of
columbine hall will be less
than you've already approved for the
blower homes
development and that seems to be the
opinion too of our
heritage colleagues
we've discussed in some detail there's
some of the um
housing that's been approved here's the
elevation of one of the units that's
been approved
that is quite a significant structure
and that's north of gipping road
there's the nutshells tea room
i just want to quickly look at
cumulative impacts because
clearly there will be some obviously
there'll be an increase
if it were approved of course there
would be additional construction traffic
in and around the
village that would have to be accepted
obviously the routes to get there would
be the subject of a
construction method statement and the
activity would be temporary only during
the lifetime of that
construction yes there will be increased
traffic associated with the new homes
but we believe that we now have
sufficient mitigation
particularly with the crossing and the
co-op to deal with that and you'll
notice that the highway authority have
no objection
to the increase in in traffic
there will be pressure additional
pressure on local facilities
and again that's a good thing in some
ways to
facilities within the local service
center but we've also
got sill that would be available
to offset some of those and you'll
notice in the 100 section 106 is
reference to education contributions
and other things so already mitigation
is being
built in there will be harm to the
character of the countryside
and there will be lots of farmland but
we believe with the enhanced
landscape package now within the scheme
that would be suitably mitigated and we
now believe that the
harm the additional harm of new
development
on this site has been adequately
mitigated in terms of the impact on the
listed building
sustainability again i just want to
dwell on this point the neighborhood
plan actually identifies
um looking after threadstone's meadow
into the future as a key action
that would come out of the neighborhood
plan and by bringing that into public
ownership i would argue
it can be properly maintained it can
have a
a management plan that that deals with
when are the hedges cut do you cut the
grass for hay
how do you manage it what species do you
put in it is it available for events
that would be up to in the first case
the council the intention would be
if the parish council wanted to pass
that on to the parish
with a maintenance dairy of 75
000 pounds but the benefit is at the
moment the farmer can
do what he or she likes with that piece
of land as
as agricultural land it is it has no
particular protection
at least with it being in public
ownership that would be safeguarded in
perpetuity
so in terms of overall sustainability
we've we've
got the transfer of thread stones meadow
it comes with a maintenance sum as i say
of
75 000 pounds it represents three
hectares of green infrastructure with
everything included
including the piece to the north it
creates new wildlife corridors there's
an attenuation pond which creates a new
wetland habitat
it the development will be uh
will come with black boxes bird boxes
the range of
eco measures that we are encouraging
more and more
we will retain the trees and hedgerows
that exists
i would argue here we've got a chance to
really increase the biodiversity
on the site and we have an opportunity
to develop a landscape management plan
for this wider
wider area in terms of bus stops stow
upland is
is quite well served by by bus stops a
lot of the routes are actually
there to get students to and from the
school but when we look at bus services
available
and the stops interesting
level of service the key service is the
three
three eight seven dieseling them to stow
market stone market
back again that that blue map shows the
routes and there are as you can see
frequent services certainly a lot better
than most
villages that that serve stow upland
in terms of the proximity of stowa sorry
stone market
i think we have to accept that already a
lot of people in
stowe upland will do their big weekly
shop in either
um asda or tesco in
stone market and because stone market is
so close i think we would argue that
in terms of sustainability that's not a
bad
thing because if you're going to those
shops it's what
two miles tops less in your car while
you're there you will visit
you probably other services and
facilities in
stone market
so in that sense proximity is not a bad
thing in terms of yes
people will use their car but it will be
for a very short journey and of course
they do have the co-op
within the village itself
still upland very close to three
mainline stations so again that
helps give it a higher sustainability
score
i've just quoted some recent appeal
statements where inspectors
are not entirely impressed by
low levels of bus frequency and we can
come on to that if we we need to i think
uh more and more inspectors are
beginning to come to the view that with
so much technology on display and that
you can click and collect or you can
have things delivered
that actually being able to have a
regular bus service is
not as important as perhaps it might
have been now we may dispute that
but that is that's the trend coming out
of appeal
decisions in terms of sustainable travel
we will secure electric vehicle charging
points to all properties
we will secure a public charging point
within the development and
you'll recall we're doing this more and
more on the larger sites
we will enhance the footpaths in the way
that i described we will secure an
increase in open space
we will when i say we of course
that isn't we as the council that's we
as the planning authority will make sure
that the developer does all of this
were plenty to position to be granted
cycle path connectivity
the controlled crossing all the other
bits and pieces are listed there
would be achieved either by the 106 or
by condition
through the reserve matters
cycling i do need to point out that in
june 2020
of this year the county council
identified 148 priority
routes for cycling one of the few in mid
suffolk stow upland identified the
thorny green to the school
as a key priority route we believe that
by
delivering a controlled crossing were
permissioned to be granted we would
already be
pump priming that whole initiative in
stowe upland
all the properties will be up to ndss
standard and we would secure the 10
renewables that's required by
policy or better if we can
in terms of the community there's
obviously the 35
affordable housing that would be secured
we get the extra open space and play
facilities
we get the connectivity enhancements the
meadow
significant 106 and seal contributions
it is still liable
i've identified the harms i've
identified the
public benefits and this is from the
report
which leads to the recommendation that's
set out
in the report chair thank you
[Music]
thank you very much indeed that was a
very comprehensive
run through there i just wonder before
we
um go to the question or we'll wait to
see what the questions bring up where
we can come in on on further information
so
i will go to questions from members and
i will also ask um councillor wellam and
councillor ebern if they have questions
so these are questions for clarity only
please they're not to sort of invite a
debate on it
um so um if we go through quickly um to
each person in turn if you have any
questions of the officer
councillor castin thank you very much
madam chairman
um i wonder if on am on one of the
larger maps
we could um point out the control
crossing
location the lane widening and the um
footpath um yes
just just to be absolutely clear where
they are in relation to the site
okay yes
so we need to go a bit further up
so application site
here church road and at that point
sorry let me take it further out i
apologize counselor that
cuts us a bit short we need
okay have we got one with the scale we
need
yes there
that one so there's there is the
application site
this is the b15 sorry
15. this is the a1120
church road that swings right up through
here
here is the co-op and here is the school
so what we will be able to achieve is a
route through here
and through either to the co-op
or for people living here if we can
improve this they would then get a way
of
coming from here across over to the
co-op
and obviously this also has good
connectivity to the
school either through here through here
or through there
so site school
co-op junction
thank you for that is that all right
then counselor casting well i just um
wondered with the um where the um
the control crossing yeah
let me see yeah there was a data a more
detailed scale i think that's what
you're probably looking for
well okay
oh don't worry i'm chancing in luck
i think you had a different slot i did
yeah
let's go crossing
47 there we go
so that's the co-op there's the
suggested location for the crossing
so yeah no i i yeah i know where that is
now
yeah there's the co-op in the picture in
the corner there
yeah okay thank you for that council
cast and councillor field any questions
sorry yeah can can i just go through
everybody please
did you miss someone now sorry
alphabetically i was next
to you no no no no i'm sorry can i just
go through the order i'm going and
you're the ward member aren't you
no no okay
at the end if i may please sorry but i'm
on the committee as well that's why it
was just
well it's not sorry because you'll be a
member won't you no problem
thank you okay um
just just looking at page 41 of the
report it talks about
the um the adverse effect of allowing
development that conflicts with the
neighborhood plan is likely to be
significant
and further on it talks about the
stalactin neighborhood plan
is part of the statutory development
plan
but it may not be robust as it as the
district council has identified
need in the emerging joint local plan
has not been met i i just wonder if you
can make that a bit clearer
clearly the neighborhood plan is made
and he's part of the statutory
development plan the district council's
plan
is still wedding its way slowly to
conclusion
so how should i really regard that uh
that
clash this is not an allocated site in
the stone market plan
as i've pointed out in the report yes
the neighborhood plan
is adopted it does form part of our
development plan but it is
clear in terms of the direction of the
council
the council is expecting stow uplands to
take a significantly larger number of
dwellings than is currently identified
in the neighborhood plan can i just
interrupt because i think that's more
for debate that's just a point that
you've made really uh councillor field
and
i think um the planning officer has sort
of
addressed that but i agree with your
questioning i think that's more for a
debate
okay i i thought it was a matter of
clarification of the
of the various well it's an
interpretation isn't it
i would have thought i mean i agree with
you from you know that you've got a made
plan and then that's up to us to make a
judgment
that the officer has mentioned um a
joint local plan which clearly isn't
made and that's up to us to make a
judgment on how we
how we view it i would have thought do
you have any further questions
no i'll leave it at that okay and then
bring that up in the debate that would
be helpful
councillor gould thank you madam chair
and you may
very quickly uh refer me to your
previous answer
because my my question is uh
not unrelated to to counselor fields
fields
and i just and indeed it might be
appropriate for someone else if there's
someone speaking about
the uh the neighborhood plan itself but
i'm i wanted to ask how the authors of
the neighborhood plan
came to assess the quantum of housing
uh required in which featuring the in in
the plan
i wonder if that's a question for um
for councillor wallam and that when he
comes to speak would you would you
consider that a better one counselor
would you like to just say yes or no and
we'll move on to you at that point
yeah i don't want to spend too much time
answering other people's questions when
i'm making my presentation so
no no we come to that afterwards okay
i'm happy to cover it
presentation who was the author of the
neighborhood plan
the the author the authors were a a
group of volunteers
headed by a charter town planner and
advised by another chartered town
planner
um and all of the uh policies and so on
were run through um district council
policy planning policy officers um
and obviously everything then went
through the inspector
right okay well we'll come back to that
point if we need to on that
um does that sort of um is that all
right with you counselor goal to do that
at that point
yes i i mind less who answers it as long
as i
i i understand how to know which is fair
enough we've had part answer there
um i i don't wish to ask any further
questions councillor hattingham
thank you yeah it's just a really quick
one um vincent he said several times the
blog site we approved it was
did we approve it or did it come through
on appeal
that's a good point
i'm gonna have to double check yeah i
think
i think i can tell you the answer to
that one because i was the chair of that
one and we refused it
and it went to the field
thought and i was just thinking you said
several times we approved that and i
thought just
really i thank you for your um
accuracy i apologize to members i wasn't
deliberately seeking to
mislead the committee that was before my
time but i should have researched it so
thank you councillor that's
a valuable um insight yeah i think what
happened there was it got
approved the outline and then we had to
approve the reserve matters which is
where
you would get your information i presume
councillor hicks do you have any
questions for clarity
no thanks not at this moment thank you
thank you
councillor humphreys no thank you madam
chair no questions
thank you councillor mansell uh thank
you chair
um i i actually have a number of
questions um i
i've honed them down to four is that
allowed would you want me to only do
three
well as long as they offer clarity and
not debate keep going
our first question do you want me to do
them all together i want to say let's do
them one at a time
right first of all can you tell me what
facilities
are currently open you know there are
some facilities at walnut tree farm
yeah at present i haven't been out on
the site
since end of march
i don't know what's happened during the
covid
situation maybe i'll ask that to
somebody else then
yeah if there's something i think you
can probably get cancer
next question the the green islands that
are part of the pavement
widening scheme uh is it
would is it are they going to be a
permeable surface or will they be hard
impermeable concrete or tarmac
they would be whatever suffolk county
council
feels appropriate for those locations
bearing in mind that they would need to
be designed to
facilitate pedestrians and
weird users do we don't
just want to ask sam if there's any
further to add to that if that's the
answer that's fine
does sam want to add anything to it yes
thank you chair
um it's it would be to suffolk county
council specifications so it would not
be permeable we do not allow permeable
surfacing within the highway i'm afraid
not the present time
so everything will be um metalled
thank you at least that's a clear answer
um
next question one of um vincent's slides
i think it was to do with the play
services
comment uh talked about protecting oaks
to the south of the site i wonder if
somebody could point them out on a map
sorry uh council i'm just getting some
slides up i think that is something
you might have to trust me that we might
we'll be looking at behind the scenes
can we start that one for the moment to
council
i just want what what does it mean
behind the scenes
i would say giving the planners the
authority to to check that but i could
be wrong
well the answer is if we're looking to
put a
tpo on something the last thing you do
is announce that you're going to do it
okay five thousand five right my last
question
um well my of the four questions that i
i
i've got um you talked about the highway
improvements around the junction of the
bead
treble one five and the a whatever it is
um
uh and i got a bit confused uh can i'd
like a bit of clarity
about the there's fifty thousand pounds
was that
either to improve the width of the
junction and put a
right only lane in and or
to do something with the cycle route
which currently stops
short of that junction if you're coming
up from stone market
was it one or the other or both sorry i
confused but you've actually got it
right
it could be both depending on how much
the improvements cost
however was another solution to come
forward from
other development because you'll recall
that in the recent past there have been
proposals for ash's farm and diapers
farm
if another solution came forward that 50
000 would all be available
for cycle improvements so what we've
done is rather than risk
losing it because we we didn't need to
put the right turn in
we have secured a cascade that then
means
we can think about cycle improvements
and again
if only 30 of that is spent on junction
improvements that gives us
20 for cycle improvements i hope that
explains it uh
yeah can i clearly can i just so that
your answer is is nice and clear but i'm
presuming that the
the right turn lane is a higher priority
than improving the cycle
path that's how it was put to us
um locally that that that
improvement to that junction was needed
okay thank you thank you councillor
mansell you asked a couple of my
questions there so it's very helpful
councillor matheson yes thank you thank
you for clarity please
yes absolutely the yes um we've just
largely addressed
the first one of my questions thank you
um i would i would say
that fifty thousand is definitely not no
what is your question so i would like
yes so can we make the priority the
cycle junction
the the next question right uh nice easy
one
um we've we've reduced the developable
area by increasing these buffers and
we've increased the number of houses
um as well as up to um
could we have the the before and after
densities on that one and perhaps we can
leave that one for a minute and i do
have an answer a bit later on but i do
have it well we have got an answer
i asked the question myself in briefings
so vents far away
the adjacent blower development has a
net
density of 43 dwellings per hectare this
if it were approved would have a net
density of 34 dwellings per hectare
with the uplifted number and the reduced
site area
developable site area thank you
and that's uh all your questions thank
you councillor yeah i've got one
one one more the um
the that really that relates to the the
protection of trees which i think
someone someone started on already
i was rather concerned to see that the
the hedge between the the site
and the arable field to the um
loosely east he's actually he's actually
quite low quite low down um can we be
assured
we're going to get some proper trees uh
into
into the um planting scheme there
not have it all cut down to three foot
yes right thank you for that thank you
councillor matheson councilor mallon do
you have any questions please
yes thank you chair although melanie
colleagues ahead of me have got to a
couple of them already
i just need the questions uh
okay can i just have a clarification um
vince you mentioned in your report that
this secures a cycle route from thorny
green to the school
um in my understanding thorny green is
immediately adjacent to the school so
i'm not sure
does that mean a road frontage cycle
route
um you know in front of the church there
you yeah i was thinking along
church road and then you you could nip
in
off of that access the vehicle access to
the school
that's just a little further south than
um
at the crown yes okay can i just check
is is
the width of the path and the bits
you're gonna take out of verge
is that fully appropriate um for cycles
and pedestrians for that yeah
i will let uh my colleague sam from
highways answer that
i believe there are sections that would
there will be pinch
still be pinched points that will be
below that but i i defer to her
advice on how you deal with a cycle
route that's less than three yes hello
um
yes uh mr pierce is correct that
it would be the majority of it is
requested to be 33 meters but there are
a number of print points
just also to let you know that there is
a scheme that suffolk county council has
been working with stowe upland parish
and the school
to get a cycle route to the school
via um there's the
thorny green area that is coming to
fruition as well
so it may not be unplanned yet but i
know that that is coming forward
any further questions
that's all chair thank you thank you
councillor uh councillor
maya any questions no chair thank you
nothing at this time
thank you councillor muller uh no
questions at this stage thank you chair
thank you councillor norris
my uh question has already been asked
thank you
well done thank you counselor stringer
thank you chair yes i'm afraid i still
have three questions
uh one of which is about the securing of
the crossing
um i've i've been doing this long enough
to
of i've seen three applications where we
tried to condition the crossing
at exactly this point and we were told
it hadn't been through it it could
wouldn't
it wouldn't pass a safety audit so can i
ask whether
this proposal has would pass such a
safety audit
uh when all the others wouldn't because
obviously if it's not safe to build we
might condition it but it then never get
built
and we've got a number of paths like
that across the district
there that is one i think for my highway
colleague to
comment on in terms of the next
next stages yes thank you
um the the parish council along with
suffolk highways has come up with a
feasibility study for a crossing
in this general area at the moment what
the
suffolk highways are proposing is that
with pedestrian surveys to be undertaken
and uh vehicle we were able to get
vehicle surveys but obviously
when it came to the the latest situation
with the pandemic we're unable to get a
a true reflection on the pedestrians
walking in the area
so that is one thing that we would ask
for
would be for pedestrian surveys to come
forward then
it has been looked at with regard to a
safety audit
with the feasibility and this location
could be looked at but there would be a
need
to talk to the adjacent landowner as in
the co-op
because we need to ask them to change
some
slight changes to their access
arrangements
obviously if they turn and categorically
say no
then we'd have to re-look at it but i
would think it would be in their best
interest
for them to be able to help us with this
crossing point
um can i actually come in there and and
just say that um
from that point of view um it would seem
sensible to should members be minded
to be looking positively at this that we
is it possible for us to put a condition
in that we get
shall we call it legwork done at an
early stage so that that can be
made very clear so that if um you do
find a suitable
and um everything ticks all the boxes
with councillor stringers
comments there um would we be able to if
we if we think on and i know we haven't
finished with cancer string
but could we put in a condition that
brings forward all those
inquiries rather than leaving it at the
end of the day is that something
possible we could do
so should i chip in i think at the
moment we're suggesting
um no occupation of the development
until that crossing is in but i think
there is you're right there is an
earlier stage that we could actually
require the
full details of that crossing to be part
of the reserved matters submission
so as you were looking at all the
reserve matters you would have that
detail in front of you
at that stage having done all the lag
work i'm sorry
yeah no having done all the legwork but
i would say that is possible but we
might want to discuss that a bit further
when we're into it
further down the road council stringer
you've got three questions and there's
some more to
i'm sorry i butted in on your thing but
yeah so so in brief the answer to the
first question is no this has not been
through a safety audit
so uh that's what i wanted to know the
you mentioned the allocations in the
draft joint local plan
uh and and you put it down as an
allocation twice and not a draft
allocation
so can you confirm that the in terms of
the joint local plan
you are referring to the first draft
and not the emerging second drop because
they may well be different
i am referring to the preferred options
document of july 2019.
yes we which is not which is
not the second draft okay we you
mentioned
that this village has a deficit
in terms of housing delivery numbers yet
having worked on a panel looking at this
for the joint local plan
we we don't do numbers per village we do
it by class of village
so i don't know how you can substantiate
how do you substantiate a deficit in one
village
when we don't look at it at planning
level with just one village we look
across it as a band of villages
i'm highlighting a distinction between
the number of allocations in the
neighborhood plan
and the number of allocations set out to
meet the
identified requirement in the draft
joint local plan
it it's a difference
that's what i have done
okay do you just mind if i come back on
that because this next question this
with my phone but it's absolutely
crucial
so so if from your point of view if the
draft
if the second draft local plan did not
include this site
would it change your mind um i think
counselor stringer that's not quite
right question to ask we haven't got all
these through and you're asking
hypothesis so
i think that's a bit of an unfair
question to ask the planner at this
stage
and i know i've worked on the jlp with
you so i know where you're coming from
well i'm happy to refer to mr isabel if
we get to that point
chip in chairman well if you think it's
appropriate yes
um well well chairman i mean we're
talking about uh
identified need and other issues and
clearly
the jlp is a draft document subject to
consultation and there is
work being done to review all of those
things what we do know is that the
draft jlp has a an identified
requirement for
houses and as in his present formulation
it talks of 752 being the allocation for
this
this particular village now all those
things may change
but those are the facts as we have them
today and
you have to make the decision on the
information as you have it before you
and in terms of an identified
requirement uh clearly
that's where the district is in terms of
its information uh and that's the
present day
uh compared to the situation that was uh
the case when the neighborhood plan was
prepared and obviously i mean i think if
you
uh refer to page 44 of the committee
report you'll see there's uh
mention of the neighborhood plans uh
teams work on
uh 40 42 sorry not 44. you'll see
there's reference to
the work the neighborhood plan group did
around this and at that time
uh they said it wasn't possible to
provide certainty on the likely
requirement for stowable and the present
um because a higher figure than that
provided for an enabled plan cannot be
ruled out so i think there was some
uncertainty about
the figure for housing uh but my
instinct is the advice the district was
giving the neighborhood plan group
when it was doing its work and at the
examination was that there was the
potential for
more houses to be anticipated at the
district level that's all i want to say
chairman
thank you for that and councillor
stringer i'm sure if you want to bring
that up in the debate that will be very
helpful
yes thank you
council of war boys
[Music]
yeah yes just well one question now the
second one was just
answered about the feasibility of the
crossing
um but this is also back back to suffolk
county council i think
it's to do the capacity of freeman um
county primary in the neighborhood plan
this was
already over subscribed in 2018
and students were being mostly
bust down to cedars primary school down
the bottom
i i assume by the 11 20 a1120
is it possible um
as we're talking about um
ensuring that the feasibilities
in the document let me go back a bit
sorry in the document oh can we have
it yeah it is but i need to put right
there are plans for expansion to freeman
cp the clear strategy for this is not
identified at this moment in time
is it possible as we talk doing the leg
legwork for the feasibility of the
crossing to also
ensure that this strategy for the
expansion
of freeman primary school is also
determined before the development takes
place
that i would suggest is a matter for our
county colleagues but what we are
suggesting
at their uh request is that we secure
the requisite education contribution
through 106 for them to be able to
provide
additional spaces by all means we can
ask them
were you minded to grant permission how
they are intending to do that
but for the purpose of this application
we are securing the sum that was
asked by suffolk county council to
provide the necessary extra spaces in
the village
okay thank you and thank you very much
thank you very much for your question
and counselor eben as the ward member
would you like to ask a question please
thank you very much indeed yes just a
quick one please um
just with regards to um planning policy
um i just wanted to know
why they hadn't there wasn't any
consultation response
from them for this particular um
application whereas there was in the
previous one and
on pages 41 to 42 um references made to
their
previous response um in your papers for
what from page 41 to page 42. so i just
wondered why there wasn't a response
for this one thank you very much chair
thank you councillor they hadn't changed
their their mind the fact that it was
allocated
in the glp was sufficient for them to
say that they would be supporting it
in in the draft yes in the draft yes
any further question councillor eban
no thank you chair thank you very much
indeed
and now um councillor wellam for
questions um
for the officer please thank you chair
can i point out some errors in some of
the slides in the description there too
please um before we go much further um
can i mean i'll put them in the form of
a question if you like but i
i mean i am aware that there are some
errors uh if we looked at
slide 47
no it isn't 47. it's the one showing
i thought it was 47 it's the one showing
the puffing crossing
that's it was that the one that was up a
minute ago
i believe it was yeah but the one where
it shows the sort of dimensions of it
and everything
yeah um because
there it is
um yeah that that drawing
is and i think sam can probably support
me on this that is
that is a a drawing or it is identical
to a drawing which was
prepared some years ago um
by suffolk highways when the
parish council were seeking to have an
uncontrolled crossing there
um and the outcome of that the
feasibility hang on
um cancer well and what's the what's the
error on this please
um it is it is purporting to show
a controlled crossing at a location
where
the um the county council has already
said
it it cannot be fitted in so why are we
showing it
so perhaps sam could answer that for us
please
yes thank you chair the the sketch
that's shown there is just showing that
the rough location of the
crossing point unfortunately we don't
have any images
of a controlled crossing point there at
present time
because it's just been put to the
applicant that they will provide it the
um the location is where we think
we can get in a controlled crossing
point
roughly in that area can i just add
something chair with your permission
yeah counselor willem is
right and i i accept that that drawing
was what was originally submitted
with this current proposal and it did
show
an uncontrolled crossing at councillor
willem's request
i negotiated a controlled crossing
and we now have a commitment from
glebmans to deliver a controlled
crossing
but what i've done there simply to
reflect that changes
identifying green new controlled
crossing and at the bottom i've got type
and detail subject to further
discussion so that was the original
drawing with an annotation to say
it will be controlled and not
uncontrolled and that detail will change
as more detail is is unearthed but
counselor william is absolutely right
that was the original drawing and
doesn't show a puffin
i think that's very helpful because um
having worked with councillor
on planning before he's very experienced
at this
matter and i'm grateful for him pointing
out
um the uh error shall we say
thank you for that and what was the
other error councilor welcome complete
on slide 51
i hope it's like side 51 i may have made
a mistake here
um the photograph that um the office now
it is i've got the wrong number it's the
one where
uh vince you said this is a photograph
of the village hall
uh with the path going in front of the
village hall
um i should get there in a moment there
we go
um that actually that actually is the
chapel
not the village hall um and
there the width there is 1.6 meters
this is one of the wider points um
there's two questions here how are you
going to deal with the worst
pinch points where you've only got one
meter available to get your cycle track
through
and the second question is and really to
sam
would she accept that 1.6 meters
that's wide enough for a shared use
cycle track beside an a road
should i just deal with the um village
hall apologies
councillor it's just that you and i have
met there
and i've unfortunately i i've assumed
that's a village hall but i'm quite
happy to accept that that was wrong and
it is in fact the chapel
but i know we met there we did with
others
thank you sam i don't know whether you
want to deal with can you comment on the
the other questions please yes we we're
not looking for a shared cycle route
actually along the air 1120 as i said
before
i know that there is a cycle scheme
being put forward by our strategy team
from foster upland to get children to
school
and that cycle scheme is coming to
fruition soon
so this isn't somewhere where we would
want cycling to be going along the
footway on as
as the councillor says along an a road
where there are
some pinch points uh along this busy
road
can i can i help further i think the
the scheme that sam is referring to the
blacktop is already on the green
and i think that is the scheme that that
has been put into the future proposals
of suffolk county council the one
that is already there on the ground and
leads across thorly green
to the high school um counselor can we
come into that when we come to your
speech rather than debating it now if
you would
okay any other questions you have
outside
i thought was slide 59 it's a it's a
slide of
threadstone's minnow which seems to show
some trees in the middle of it
i think i think that uh that's artistic
license
um but more importantly i think it was
on slide 67 when
um the presenting officer was talking
about the key views out of the village
and he was saying that the um
there isn't a key view towards the site
that is because that's it that is
because
the key that is showing the key views
out of the village
um paragraph 5 4 13
of um of the neighborhood plan
speaks about the valued role of the open
agricultural character of and around
this site so
please don't think that because
there isn't as a question
what is the question well it's really i
know it's a correction that that
uh well we're on questions really you
know you've got you you'll have your
time to tell us
all this in your in your ward now okay
right
last one last last point on the slides
and that is um what are the
environmental improvements or the
environment
improvements of the 1120 1115 junction
i believe i've described those in terms
of the uh
was that was that the tarmacking of some
of the grass
to make a cycle track in terms of
the environment of that yes
i wasn't describing that as an
environmental in terms of
of green and biodiversity that's just
the junction environment so apologies if
that has
has resulted in any confusion
um yeah that's that's fine
am i allowed to ask the officer if he
has read
the feasibility study for the crossing
point
which has been completed by suffolk
county council
and if he has and if he has it to hand
perhaps he could read the summary and
the conclusion because this is
this is vitally important to dealing
with this
this matter because the conclusion is
read on the various points it is not
feasible
so we're talking about carrying out a
safety
audit when the feasibility study has
already been done so
there's no need for doing the leg work
much of the leg work has already been
done painful
it's it's your question you're going
into debate keith you've got to just ask
the question has he read it and
and then we can talk about it when we
get to you i'm sorry but this is just
slowing down our sort of process that we
want you to tell us everything
at the right time if you would please
right
okay well should i also can you answer
the question
have you read it yes or no i don't need
to because i rely on my highway
colleagues to give me highway advice
okay well we'll come on to that when we
when we go through the debate
okay um there's a much further question
could i could i have it explain to me
what a grampian condition is
because can you do that for us please
yes a grampian condition
is named after the authority in scotland
that first
used it and it is it goes along the
lines of
you cannot do something until something
else happens
that something else in this case would
be the delivery of the
crossing
so just to be clear the delivery of the
crossing has to precede the building of
the houses
occupation is what we are suggesting
well this is where i
this is where i worried so does that
therefore mean
that the houses could be built and sold
um and suffolk county council are still
saying it's not feasible
what we discussed in the in the earlier
preamble was a mechanism whereby
that might be possible to avoid that
situation and we were going to come on
to that in the discussion
um are you thank you i think i think
that's sufficient councillor
we will hear you on your full
explanations
concerns and everything in your ward
member bid
unless there is a specific question we
really must move on
uh one specific question and that is to
do with
the the comment that the the officer has
said what is clearly evident is that
church road has an adequate footway
um now does he consider that a
footweight less than one meter wide is
adequate
is he aware that suffolk county council
and their road safety officer
has considered it unsafe and unsuitable
and set aside funds for a scheme
to provide an off-road facility
and could he therefore explain why the
committee should take
his advice on pedestrian safety rather
than that of the road safety officer
because the inspector has it
hadn't allowed 175 dwellings to be
uh serviced from church road in terms of
pedestrian activity
and decided not to refuse it on highway
safety grounds
right okay thank you for that
so um we don't have a representative
from the parish council although we do
have councillor welum i believe
you're still with the parish council are
you not councillor wella
i am yes yeah i don't know um okay
uh we don't have an objector or a
supporter so we'll
ask the applicant to speak stuart carvel
um you have three minutes to speak if
you would please
um thank you very much for the officer
and his comprehensive um report and
presentation
um following the committee's decision to
refuse that first application in january
we carefully consider those reasons for
refusal and have sought to
bring back um to the committee
addressing your concerns
through this new planning application
i'm extremely grateful for your
assistance and the local authority and
the county council for
um working with us on those
the application now more closely aligns
with the dwelling numbers expected
across this and the neighboring law site
in the council's emerging local plan
in response to the comments by the
committee regarding thraso's menu
the has been pulled back significantly
allowing further green space
uh and areas for civil drainage instead
of the
council's flooding team's requirements
um there is a commitment to finding the
solution for the crossing to the cart
for the benefit of all residents
and which will be secured as as we've
previously discussed
as well as those improvements around the
church road and stone market road
junction
the scheme isn't a sustainable location
identified in the council's a14 growth
corridor with close
access to services and facilities in
stomach including
the mainline railway station and we have
discussed
um with members of the parish council
about to allow that transfer
of threats into their into the public
ownership for the benefit and
how they wish to manage it with an
appropriate um
payment for them to do so and the
section 106 is really a draft stage
sorry an advanced stage and there's
payments towards
the school places and preschools where
those are necessary
um the parish to also receive 25 of
civil funding
as it hasn't made neighborhood plan in
this situation um
now just to conclude our express request
respectfully the grant plan permission
for this
because it meets the council's emerging
local plan and importantly secures
neighborhood plans
um aspirations of threadstone's meadow
and improved connectivity for the
benefit of all the residents of
stockland
thank you you for that do we have
questions
for the applicant and i'll run through
again in the same order if i may please
counselor carsten no questions thank you
councillor field
no questions councillor gould no
questions
i don't either councillor lavina
hattingham no thank you
councillor hicks no thank you councillor
humphreys
no thank you councilmember
no thank you councillor matheson no
thank you
councillor marlon no questions thank you
chad
councillor mayor nothing thank you
councillor muller
none thank you chair councillor norris
no questions thank you
councillor stringer uh just just one
chair
uh it's over the crossing the the
drawing of your
potential crossing how will
the new houses access the road
with an island in the way because the
the drawing doesn't your drawing doesn't
show it
but the reality does because i remember
being on the committee
opposite the co-op there are two new
dwellings with two new driveways there
exactly where your island is going to be
so how will those properties turn left
and right coming out of their driveway
with an island in the way
the drawing proposed was an indicative
location and as
mr pearce described that was for an
indicative location
of where um a crossing could be but the
precise details will be subject to
um those detailed road safety orders so
that detail will
will come at a later stage
so so you weren't able to show is then
is there no possibility you could show
us a plan
of a possible location rather than one
where it's not possible
the it would have as i say would have to
go through that full road safety audit
process
in terms of um the type of crossing to
be delivered
whether that would be um the toucan or
the puffin and then the exact location
and it would go through that stage one
and stage two road safety order process
so
that that information isn't here at the
moment but that is what will come
through as required by the condition
thank you councillor stringer is that
sufficient for your questioning
yes thank you thank you councillors
drinker counselor boys
no questions thank you councillor ebern
no question secretary and council of
wallam
no questions thank you thank you for
that
so um i will now come to the ward
members and
um first of all may we have councillor
ebern please
um thank you very much chair and thank
you very much to officers for the
um comprehensive presentation
um firstly i'd like to support
the parish council in asking that this
application be refused
it's against the neighborhood plan as
well as the nppf
national planning policy framework so
it's against the most local of policies
as well as the national there's lots of
references
within the papers and the presentation
to the emerging draft joint local plan
um however the priority really should be
the neighborhood plan this application
is also
outside the settlement boundary and the
issue
with their with that is the previous a
previous application
um which was refused by this
com by this council and then went to
appeal
was on the edge of the village boundary
and there is an edge there that had
planting and trees and so on as a
landscape buffer
we've now got another edge you know one
edge
follows another edge and then where will
the edges end
the edge of this village should be the
landscape that
we are currently looking at which is a
rural
landscape that is not
special maybe in the official definition
of the word
but it is special to the residents of
stowe upland and it is a very valuable
landscape
you're asking you're being asked to
approve this application
and that much discussion
so far or questioning or information
is about proposed housing numbers for
stockland
it's a village of 600 of approximately
600 homes
so already approved is a significant
number
which will more than a half again for
the verge
of 600 homes and even if you were to go
to look at the
proposed allocations in the emerging
joint local plan
that would more than double the size of
the village and their own neighborhood
plan has put forward significant numbers
which are already being met
the main changes that have been
made to this application versus the one
that was refused
back in january are to do with the
amount of housing adding another 10
extra housing
some landscape changes within the site
and
the proposed crossing by the newly
revamped co-op
however notwithstanding the neighborhood
plan
there are three main reasons why this
should be refused
we've already had questions with regards
to the crossing
and there isn't any firm confirmation
that this can actually be achieved i've
sat in planning
committees where we've had detailed um
drawings from
highways it's stating exactly how a
crossing can be
achieved and i'm very concerned that we
can't won't be able to achieve
what is needed and there won't be the
money for it
we'd always also need funding
to actually have a cycle way and
pedestrian walkway that's safe for
people to use and
if all the funding is used up in a in a
crossing that
might will take more than is already
being asked for
and because what we're looking at isn't
necessarily achievable
then that's going to be very difficult
secondly there's a discussion about
sustainable location
the distance to train station in stone
market
now that's only possible if you don't
commute on particular days of the week
and you've got very set working times in
terms of using the buses
and ideally you'd want people to cycle
into the station
but again there isn't a safe cycle route
and i would have hoped to have seen
funding towards one connecting up the
route that goes
um through other parts of stone market
and thirdly the rural landscape will be
irretrievably damaged
it's an open rural landscape as i've
said and landscape buffers
such as trees will change this as much
as housing states will
so we have got further
obstructions within the landscape than
already exist
but most importantly as the parish
council said this is contrary to their
their own neighborhood plan policies
not much has really changed from the
previous application you refused
a few more houses an unworkable highway
solution
and a landscape buffer in the rural age
of village area that should really
remain open and for these reasons
i urge you to refuse this application
thank you very much
thank you councillor eben now um
do you have questions um would you would
you be happy if
we have the questions to you first
counsellor before um
councillor wellam says his bit can we do
it in that basis i think it would be
preferable to
have questions to both of us if that's
all right sophie
first hear from councillor first okay
then fine
i just wanted to know which way you
wanted it councillor wellum if you'd
like to give us your views on this
i know um there was a lot you were going
to tell us earlier
so please thank you yeah can i can i put
together my own views and the views of
the parish council so that you get them
all in one go rather than separately
go keep going yeah yep okay thank you
so here we go again this time the
committee has to consider an application
for 80 homes
having refused an application for 70
homes on the same site
the officer is correct in his report to
state that the neighborhood plan must be
given full weight
but then instead of following the mppf
he sets about trying to persuade the
committee that despite the evidence
he recommends approval despite the
conflicts with the neighborhood plan
the starting point for considering this
application
is that stoke upland has an approved
neighborhood plan
approved and made by this council just a
year ago
it has a site allocation in line with
advice from planning offices at the time
and accepted by the examiner and the
examiner
the application side is not included in
that allocation
or within the proposed settlement
boundary
paragraph 12 of mppf states where a
planning application conflicts with an
up-to-date development plan
including any neighborhood plan
permission should not usually be granted
so the officer needs to produce strong
reasoning
why the neighborhood plan should not be
overridden and there are no
such reasons given thus far the proposal
is in conflict with part
nine of the nppf especially paragraphs
103
and 102. due to the distance from the
site
to employment opportunities retail
outlets etc
and the lack of a bus service except
very occasionally a bus to stone market
the majority of trips will be by private
car
the value of threadstone's meadow has
been reduced by the proximity of new
homes already
and that makes it more important that
there is no building along the west side
the landscape consultant to the
neighborhood plan
makes it clear a proposal in this
location will negatively
impact the rural settlement fringe
character
the development will have a detrimental
impact on the rural setting of the
village
and will be further encroaching into the
countryside
there is a requirement to retain the
open agricultural use of this land
for arable or pasture
the minor economic benefits are far
outweighed by the greater environmental
and social dis benefits
but the proposal is clearly not in
accordance with its council's
development plan and that points members
directly towards a refusal
mid-south has a five-year supply of
housing land local schools are full
health centres can take no more patients
community infrastructure is already
stretched and the current village
facilities
will not be able to provide fully for
the residents of the dwellings already
approved
i'm pleased that since the previous
application was refused suffolk highways
have accepted that highway improvements
are required
the parish council back in january
commissioned suffolk highways to carry
out a feasibility study
for a crossing facility of the a1120 at
the co-op filling station
after around four months and using a fee
of four thousand pounds
the report was received stating that no
feasible solution could be identified
this was followed a little later by an
email from today's presenting officer
explaining that the reasons for refusal
of the earlier application had been
overcome
as cladman would provide a control
crossing
subject to scc approval the parish
council has already been given the
information that this committee needs
there is no feasible controlled crossing
scheme
this is a key element of the office's
argument and it falls at the first
hurdle
it would be very unwise to approve an
application
with a planning condition that cannot be
implemented and it would be equally
unwise to approve an application
which would be unsustainable and just
add to the traffic and safety hazards
which already exist i was advised by
one senior planning officer that for the
application to be refused
a site within the village to accommodate
70 to 80 new homes
would need to be identified a site to
accommodate those
homes was put forward the landowners are
willing
the site was considered by the cross
party joint local plan working group
the result of their deliberations in
respect of that suggestion
are key some of those in this meeting
know the result
and may already be aware that this site
will not be
in the next version of the site
allocations
i was told that information would be
made available to me but subsequently
i've been told otherwise
so if there are members of that working
group on this committee who know the
outcome and if that outcome is for this
application site to be saved from
development
will they vote for refusal today in any
case
surely it is unsafe to approve this
application
for so many other reasons and i wonder
if
planning policy could have changed their
advice they could have given some
further information
as a result of the working group
meetings
the parish council are totally against
allowing this development
their reasons are clearly set out in
their objection letter
due to holiday commitments and a feeling
of pressure from planning officers to
accept that development is
inevitable they are not entering this
meeting
at the request of offices the parish
council have set out in the letter the
conditions
under which the council will take on the
land you will see that parish council
have
has again reiterated its objection to
the application
members have strong grounds for refusing
this application
based on nppf paragraph 12
paragraphs 102 103 and neighborhood plan
policies
offices appear to have assessed this
application on the basis of paragraph
11d of the neighborhood
of the mppf as if the neighborhood plan
does not exist
it is clear in any case that the social
road safety and environmental
dis benefits outweigh any economic
benefit
i go back to paragraph 12 of nppf
which states where planning application
conflicts with an up-to-date development
plan
including any neighborhood plan
permission should not
usually be granted so i conclude
this application needs to be refused
chair if i might just button very
quickly
i think someone is sharing their screen
possibly
um could everyone just check i might be
someone said it's possibly counselor
gould but i can't see who is on my
screen who is actually sharing so
if i think it's now gone back to yes i
believe it's returned to normal now
chair thank you very much
guilty is charged uh phone chair
nothing gets passed does does it
um it was it the only one person sharing
i thought there were others
so chair there was a um i think it was
possibly council reborn as well by
mistake as well but um
we're now back to as we were
okay right thank you um
can we um go on to uh
questions for the ward members and do
you both want to
sort of answer them as they come up um
we'll see what the questions are and
whoever can go for it
i'll leave you uh counsellory burn and
counselor wellam is that all right
yeah okay so councillor custon do you
have any questions for the ward members
thank you very much madam chairman um
this is
um this is directed uh um
board members and the parish council
members
um are there this is the viability of
the arable land
question do you know of any issues that
have affected the activity of farming on
the land um
notably objections from residents to um
the mud on the roads and issues like
that
[Music]
no i'm i'm not i'm not aware of i'm not
aware of anything
there was one encouragement after
threadstone's meadow
by uh somebody in an off-road vehicle
who went round around in circles and
then
drove away but that's the only problem
that i'm aware of
in respect of that land none for me
okay thank you very much thank you
councillor field
thank you i think that presentation was
pretty comprehensive
perhaps the only question is around
numbers i mean
clearly the district has to deliver a
number of houses
for people need those
[Music]
i willem to say there were alternative
sites to this ones which had been agreed
could you just confirm that again please
yeah um there is an approval for 143
which was not
in the neighborhood plan um
the the neighborhood plan and the
presenting officer quite rightly said
the neighborhood plan
should be updated annually well um
because of covid that
has not yet been possible and it's now
probable that uh rather than update it
at the minute
uh would be sensible to wait for the
next stage of the
joint local the draft joint local plan
to come out um
so there would be there would be
different numbers um the
uh there are 300 i think it's 300
shown uh on land owned by
uh nearer to the a14 with direct access
from that site
uh onto the one one one five and
from there straight down to the station
so that is
that is a site which parish council has
discussed that site
with the owner and agent and various
other people who would like to develop
that site
originally they wanted between 600 and
650 homes on that site which
parish council were very unhappy about
the
draft joint local plan suggests 300 and
it would make much more sense for there
to be
370 say on there
rather than 300 near stone market and 70
as far away as you can possibly get so
it makes much more sense
for the for the the 70 or 80 or however
many
might be approved for this site or
or applied for on this site much more
sensible
for those to be um to be nearer to stone
market
and and i put that suggestion forward
and i hope it has been
discussed by the working group i had
hoped and i'd asked this question at
council
that that i'd be told whether or not
that bid was successful and what the
what the next stage of the local plan
would show uh but i have i was
originally told yes you can have that
information subsequently i've been told
not but i believe that there are some
who are sitting today who may know the
answer to that
sorry chair may i just make a very quick
observation if i may
yes obviously we have the application in
front of us all rather you have the
application in front of you today
the jlp preferred options document is a
published document
i think the um the matter that
councillor wellington is referring to
i'm not aware of the the outcome of that
it's certainly not in a published
version of the jlp and the local
development
uh strategy suggests that we won't be
adopting a jlp
until 2122 it is
um you are under a duty now to consider
what's in front of you
rather than what might be available
sometime next year
sorry to cut in but i think i needed to
stress that thank you yes
um yeah chairman yes can i can i just
chip in
yes you can actually because i was going
to call you in on on one or two other
issues but we're on questions for the
ward members but
um some of your comments might um help
the question as well yeah i'll
i'll i'll deal with it as you as you
wish chairman there are a couple of
points on on both crossing and
neighborhood plan which i think is worth
addressing but in terms of in terms of
the work around the draft jlp
it's still a draft so any discussion
that has been had around
uh the the draft documentation is still
draft and you have to decide the
application not on
on that but on the facts that you have
before you and the material
considerations as they present
themselves which i think i did say
earlier
the end result is i think you know
whatever the jlp does with
this site or any other is not for the
consideration of a development control
committee on
or a planning referrals committee um the
other points on the crossing gem do you
would come back to those yeah no you
might as well just do it now in case the
questions come up for the ward members
thank appreciate the appreciate the
opportunity
um so as i understand it the
uh the crossing question um is is
something which i believe the earlier
uh provision of a crossing is not the
same as what's currently being uh
in concept and and as as as mentioned by
events
we take our advice and stuff at county
council highways and i would suggest
that you take the opportunity of
asking sam harvey just to to pick out
the detail of that because
this question of safety audit on a
crossing and the previous design of
a zebra crossing which i think on this
busy road is a problem
i don't think that would necessarily be
the case for some other design of
crossing
and i understand that there have been
accidents on this point with people
crossing to the shop so actually there
is a
a clear highway benefit to delivering a
crossing here and and strictly speaking
the question of whether that's
a necessary benefit i mean it's
certainly probably a benefit to the
village it's almost certainly a benefit
to future occupants of this development
but arguably
um there the question of of timing we
can
we can discuss the question of how to to
look at that
uh it's provision there are conditions
there is a planning obligation those are
the discussion
in debate if this is the direction the
application goes but in terms of the
start of a 10 which appears to be
councilwoman and another's starter that
that
this is fundamentally flawed
that's not the advice as i have it from
county highway authority and perhaps at
that point i would suggest you might
want to take
the advice of sam harvey as as the
horse's mouth if i put it like that
secondly uh the question that they put
plan there are some points on there but
i think probably better to do with the
crossing is one thing
and perhaps if i may come back to the
neighborhood plan point later on
chairman because
i think there are some important
considerations which i don't share
councillor willem's view over and it
might be best to explain those down the
line thank you jim
thank you for that and uh thank you for
um
everybody's patience um we
have questions for the ward members um
i think councillor field i think you've
finished haven't you we're on to
um councillor gould yes i had finished
thank you councillor thank you
and the uh question uh
that i was going to ask uh and the
thought behind it
have been addressed really in what's
been said so
i will be saying something about this
when we come to
to debate but i think that's the most
appropriate part of the meeting
thank you thank you um councillor
paddingham
sorry it's councillor eben here can i
ask if i find it very hard to hear
councillor gould very clearly and i was
wondering it sounds a bit like he's on a
speakerphone
and whether he's he's actually in a big
chamber i think
exactly so yes i just wonder if he can
unless he has a puppet on his head i
don't think there's going to be much
better
we'll relay if you if you struggle thank
you
councillor hattingham um no i haven't
got any questions now either thank you
thank you councillor hicks
nothing to add thank you thank you
councillor humphreys
i'm sure yes please uh just one question
much has been said about the cycle
routes between stone market and still
upland
just for clarity now i use that roots a
lot on my bicycle for fitness
and i see a lot of commuters using it as
well and could either reward members
tell me how many accidents or incidents
have been with cyclists say
i don't know over the last 10 years on
that particular stretch
please i think for that
one you'd have to ask highways that yeah
to get that feed
okay um can highways jump in and answer
the question
yes um any any observations on the
cycling and accidents on that route yeah
if you just give me a moment i'll just
uh look at the data
okay we'll come back to that in a moment
um any other questions councillor
humphreys
no thank you madam chair we'll we'll get
the answer to that shortly as soon as
sam has it
um councillor mansell do you have
questions for the ward members
uh yes please i i have i'd like to go
back to an
earlier question that i asked and i have
one other question
uh first question was can you tell me
what facilities
open to the public are available at
walnut
tree farm and that's my first question
uh yes i can um as you probably know
that there was a range of facilities
there including post office
currently uh postcovid there is a coffee
shop
which does uh a range of food
not the wide range that it has done in
the past but
what will happen when we come completely
out of lockdown i don't know
but uh the intention as i understand it
um and so can i just confirm there is no
longer a post office
there is no longer a post office right
thank you and my other question
maybe relates a bit to the other
comments about cycling
um now could either you or councillor
ebern
as possibly less frequent cyclists than
myself
um how confident would you be about
cycling
from this that's not clarity that's just
uh no i want to know if it is a feasible
cycle route from this development would
you feel comfortable
well yeah no sorry all right is it a
feasible cycle route
from this development along thorny green
road
to join the cycle path that is adjacent
to the b treble 1 5
um further down to go over the bridge to
the a14
market that is a question that i can
answer because
there is a lot of evidence of cyclists
using the narrow foot way
to cycle from the brawl homes estate um
to thorny green um because they feel
unsafe
on on the road um that is that is a
problem
uh and the um pcsos have been out and
had a look at that problem
and have issued words of advice
i think can i just interrupt there with
you councillor
the um cycle strategy that suffolk
county council have got involved does
that include all these sorts
of things as well um
because i think we're debating something
that we shouldn't be debating it's just
a question really does it
you know do you feel safe yes or no i
think the point is that we've had to
call the pcso's out on several occasions
using the um referral forms that's
recycling questions because we're not in
debate we're just in class
questions for clarity please and we are
really winding into debate
so can you ask a further question
councillor mansell if there is no
i i don't think i've got an answer
because uh neither of the ward members
have
talked about thorny green road are you
telling me that there are traffic
incidents
on thorny green road rather than the a
road
there are incidents on police have been
called to incidents on thorny green road
well particularly where it becomes
gipping road alongside the
the the site
okay right thank you councillor matheson
i thought the war members were admirably
clear thank you
thank you councillor marlon
thank you church just a quick question
on the
new junction into the bloor development
which i understand will take all the
road traffic from this new development
as well
um is there any problems already with
the capacity of that junction
that you're aware of um can i just stop
you there that's a question that
i think sam should be answering should
it not
i think it's a question about about how
do residents use that junction
um um and if i could answer that
question
it is that there are some residents
get frustrated waiting to turn right and
so
they turn left out of that housing
estate and they take the can
the count the country lanes to get to
stone market rather than using the main
road
so they they they travel on farm roads
single track roads rather than the uh
the a road because
because of the congestion turning right
out
and that's with the law site not fully
occupied
to be fair it's probably 70 occupied
look i'm sorry we're into debate and we
are not debating these are
questions for clarity please not what
happens or what
might happen you know we've got to get
clarity now because we're debating we've
got to go forward
okay do you have any further proper
questions for clarity
uh no further questions apologies chair
thank you
it's it's just everybody's doing it and
you were last in line sorry
councillor mayor no questions thank you
councillor norris
no questions anchor councillor stringer
yeah
yes chair just two if i may uh have
have you assessed uh with your work with
the neighborhood plan the adopted
neighbourhood plan in scotland
have you assessed the impact of
approving this site would have on that
neighbourhood that current neighborhood
plan
uh and the second question uh was
have you have you have you can you
confirm
that there are dwellings cited opposite
filling station
that are not shown on the plan of the
potential crossing
the the second one is probably the
easier question uh
uh to be honest i didn't i didn't look
at that it was so small on the screen
but when i when i saw a fuller scale
drawing
there there are two there are two
dwellings there two new accesses
onto the a1120 directly opposite the
filling station
um and so they may well have not been on
the plan
um they are fairly recent so they may
well have not been on the plan
um well turning to the the the
neighborhood plan and what the
the parish councils and the communities
views on um
on it might be um well
a key element of the neighborhood plan
is protecting the northern fringe of
stone upland
especially threadstone's meadow if we
go back the neighbourhood plan was
drafted by a team of volunteers
and and they were led by professionals
um and
he was submitted to the district council
offices few minor changes
and it has since been adopted by
by the uh council and is part of the
development plan
and the community should be able to
expect that mid-suffolk district council
respect the importance of the
neighbourhood plan
which is key to the development of the
village
now the landscape appraisal the unless
government appraisal is part of the
neighborhood plan
and identified the uh the application
site
and land to the north west of it as
important open land that's the fields
uh away away from the village from that
site
um and and the landscape architect
said that they should remain so
well um can you be brief on this please
because this is questions for clarity
not to debate the entire neighborhood
plan
no no i was asked i was asked what the
what the effect might be
um yeah well that's that's supposition
what i was saying you want clarity on
questions of the
issues that aren't now yeah right
the what the what the power what the
parish and the residents feel is
that if permission were given for this
then there there'd be further housing to
the north and it would have to come the
traffic would come through
the village it's totally against the
direction of growth
of the neighborhood plan and what the
community expects
also they they expect threadstone's
meadow
to remain safe and without any further
development alongside it
so i mean in short uh i think i think it
blows it blows
the neighborhood plan out of the water
and would indeed
i think you finished that answer to that
question admirably
so thank you for your comments
councillor stringer do you have a
further question for carrick
this one is a straight yes or no
did the uh the parish council
did it submit uh a refreshed
plan to the joint local plan draft
that show a greater number of houses
that were allocated in the neighborhood
plan
um well only in respect of housing
allocation but yes
um the parish council and i on behalf of
the parish council and behalf of the
community
submitted uh a revised housing
allocation
that's right that's all i want to know
thank you chair thank you very much
andrew
councillor stringer sorry council of war
boys questions please and
questions if you would thank you uh no
further questions thank you madam chair
thank you very much right
so we're open to debate so we'll go
around
um sorry madam chair oh i beg your
pardon what
yeah just to come back to camp
councillor hunter free's a question
sorry yeah um at the moment i'm still
looking on the database
record regarding the accidents there are
a number of accidents but unfortunately
i can't see if there's a cyclist
involved there are about five or six
accidents
on the a um a1120 in that area
but sadly i can't see the details but
i'm carrying on looking
right thank you um can i just remind
members i'm not using the hands up
system i'm going through a to z now open
for debate please
so if we can go quickly on uh to the
debate
and if we can have councillor casting
please
thank you very much madam chairman um so
the um previous application was
um refused the um i think this new
application is an improved layout
the um buffer protects the um
biodiversity in the meadow
um the the blue homes development has
actually got dwellings closer
to the um to the meadow than this
development it's a it's a good amenity
to for that transfer of trad stone
meadow for one pound
the crossing widening and their extended
footpath
are also an improvement as will the
cycle route
be and improvements the a1120 and the b
treble 1 5. the um
the it is with the joint local plan
it's outside of the neighborhood plan i
think
we've got to have an important
discussion on the weight
that the neighborhood plan carries in
this
instance um this this for me i think is
the key issue here
um i'll listen to debate and um
thank you very much um well actually
councillor casten you've brought up a
very good point and i think um
philip wants to comment regarding the
neighborhood plan which i think would
help us
all a little and let's hear what he has
to say please
thank you chairman yes um it's it's
always unfortunate when you have a
neighbourhood plan which is in tension
with
um what you have in the district and now
bear in mind that
uh as a district we refused an earlier
application i think it was that was back
in february from memory
uh that the earlier decision notice uh
went out and that was a decision which
was an overturn at committee
uh and members uh council field and
others i think made particular reference
to particular points around
uh provisions in in the the the stone
upland neighborhood plan
well since that time i mean we have seen
other things uh uh emerges
as they have and as an officer point of
view i think
we take the view that there is a tension
here with a neighborhood plan and that's
unfortunate but we do need to take this
in the context of the material
considerations in the round and we
cannot simply
uh uh unfortunately apply the
neighborhood plan and
give effect to it where material
considerations take us in that that
uh that that other direction um i
i uh reference was made to uh the nppf
and the presumption in favor of
sustainable development not being
engaged where you have a neighborhood
plan which is up to date
there is a presumption uh at 11d
uh there is a point in the neighborhood
in the the nppf which
uh talks about uh not following that
presumption in favor of sustainable
development where the adverse impact of
allowing development
uh would be likely to significantly and
demonstrably outweigh the benefits
now i think officer's point of view here
is that actually there is
uh in in this revised application there
is not the adverse impact which would
mean that the presumption did not apply
again take you back to the the housing
numbers that
underpin uh the development that you
have before you this morning
this afternoon uh you've clearly got a
difference in approach between what the
neighborhood plan actually allocated
and let's not deal with the speculation
about what might be in the joint local
plan
to any grand degree we know that there
are housing numbers which underpin the
joint local plan and wherever that
housing goes
we have to as a district deal with the
applications that are before us when
when they are made and we have an
opportunity to deal with housing here
and now
and and that is part of this and we know
that certainly in terms of the
joint local plan there is uh an
allocation
of dwellings amongst various different
settlements which
uh vincent described in his presentation
and
if one were to follow that you'd clearly
have a considerable amount more growth
in stowe upland which is at odds with
the neighborhood plan and there's no
doubt about that
but since uh since that decision was
taken i think we have seen other
distinct
decisions by the secretary of state
which i do think bear upon this and
i i think it's important to note that uh
gladman amongst others are perfectly
well aware of these we had a decision in
uh in our fellow council at baber in
long melford back on the 1st of april
unfortunate timing perhaps because in
that instance there was work being done
on the neighborhood plan and there was a
site came forward
which i think was in tension with that
in that instance
and mr stroud can comment on the
particulars of that public inquiry
because he gave evidence to it the
secretary of state concluded that there
was
uh there was a need for for housing in
the locality and that that attracted
significant weight and that's not an
isolated case this secretary of state
has given
very substantial weight to that that
identified need for housing in other
cases that we're aware of across the
country and
to be honest uh my advice to committee
is that if you do not give
the need for new homes and the provision
of homes against identified need
if you do not give that significant
weight there is a question as to whether
or not that's a reasonable approach
i think clearly you've got to find
considerable unacceptable harm in any
given case
uh in order to outweigh that sort of uh
emphasis and
you know this is a decision as i say
which gladman are perfectly well aware
because they were the appellants in that
instance
so uh in terms of the neighborhood plan
i think there is a question about
whether that
adequately meets the need that we have
for the future
whether uh whether actually there is an
open question about that housing need
and
whether the benefits of this development
and there are a number of benefits here
over
that which was previously refused and
now provide a balancing factor and
as councillor casten said is it
absolutely what committee is here to do
which is to look at weight
and to attach weight to the various
considerations uh
the the neighborhood plan as it as it
stands
uh was quoted in the earlier uh in the
earlier refusal in relation to various
different
issues those have to some debate degree
been addressed i think the question of
connectivity
and indeed perhaps the benefit of the
crossing uh to
the co-op uh facilities is a matter
which perhaps it's worth speaking to
or asking sam harvey to talk to the the
safety audit aspects of that as i said
earlier
but ultimately the earlier law
development was quite acceptable to a
secretary of state's inspector
at that time so i i think one has to be
quite aware of that so
in essence chairman yes councillor
casten is absolutely right this is about
weight
whether the development plan including
the maid neighborhood plan
serves the function it needs to and we
have a core strategy and
and uh housing policies which are out of
date for the purposes of the presumption
in favor of sustainable
development our conclusion is that
in this instance the benefits there is
not the adverse impact which would lead
us to conclude that
uh there is a a uh an effect on the
neighborhood plan which would lead us uh
to
uh a a refusal against the presumption
that said i'm sure other members will
have different views and this ultimately
bears on weight thank you jim
thank you thank you for that um
cancer gutter i've got my hand up so i
want to ask a question on that point
well mr isabel is that possible or do i
ask questions when it comes to my turn
can you wait until your turn please yes
thank you thank you very much i
i i wasn't well i was ignoring you but i
wasn't
um i was hoping to get to you quicker um
councillor
field thank you chair
yes follow a long spiel from
mr isbell i i find
certainly i provide great weight to the
need
for housing and occasionally i've
wondered
why there is such resistance to these
sites on this particular side
of stone market we're well aware that
they
we rejected the blue site a long time
ago and that was passed on
appeal this site
is at the edge of the countryside but
there is a rather large and sprawling
farm site
not very far just one field away from it
to the north i think
so i do wonder uh whether this is not
an appropriate site i know before we
rejected it and i think i had some hand
in that
and one was concerned about the comments
of the
the the links to the the to the main
village and through the stone market the
footwear has been narrow
the cycle provision being distinctly
limited
and concerns greatly about the crossing
over to the
uh the co-op and in addition to go on
one more fredson's meadow was
closely overlooked by housing
and i when i read the papers i was
somewhat pleased to see
all those issues seem to be addressed
so that left me with one point
paragraph 14 of the mppf talking about
the adverse impact of allowing
development that conflicts with the
neighborhood plan
is likely to be significant it sort of
says the adverse impact of allowing
development it doesn't talk about the
adverse impact of that development
itself then
it's physically adverse and so it just
says
the problem of allowing development that
conflicts with the neighborhood plan
so i find that worries me considerably
we've pushed people
into neighborhood plans and we should
take note of those neighborhood plans
there clearly is the problem that
neighborhood plans tend to be
tightly turned drawn around existing
developments or those that have had
approval
and provide very little scope for
additional
development i'm not sure that's totally
true in this stone market
in the stateplan case as councillor
william mentioned
so i certainly find out some differences
and as usual we say i will listen to the
rest of the debate
um particularly those difficulties have
been greatly amplified by discussion of
the
at the pedestrian crossing uh
that sounds increasingly like a bit of
fantasy there are safety issues and it
sounds awfully unlikely for that to go
ahead
and i can't i'm totally convinced that
we could put a condition
in a grampian condition that would
prevent any development
unless the position and capabilities of
that crossing were agreed
so i am still in the sort of uh minded
to refuse
state but not yet made my mind up
okay thank you for your comments
counselor um and you've just raised an
issue that maybe sam
could help us a little bit on the
crossing issue
could you sort of amplify a little bit
more for us on that please
yes thank you chair um basically the the
report that um
the parish council had suffolk highways
put forward
there were three positions considered
near the co-op
um each position was considered in their
own
location but one of the things that they
did say was that it's very difficult to
put down where the best places for a
crossing until you have
a pedestrian crossing survey
so the crossing point has to be really
on the pedestrian desire line
if there is a signal controlled crossing
opposite
the um the co-op
then we would have to be talking to the
accesses
to the co-op to see if we can change
their accesses to allow us to put this
crossing point in
there was a an idea to have a crossing
more to
the west close to the junction with a
b11
15 but this wouldn't necessarily be on
the desire line
so there is enough visibility
on the location that is put forward at
the moment
which is obviously the co-op but there
is some work that needs to be done
before we can
categorically say this is where it's
going
i feel as a designer myself i've been in
highways
um design for 30 years
there is a chance to be able to put some
sort of crossing here not a zebra
because you can't put it on an a road
without
that volume of traffic but you can put
in either a toucan
or a crossing a puffin crossing
we also this development
you could say that actually if it didn't
bring it forward this crossing point
it wouldn't still be it wouldn't be
severe
it would there it is a nice thing to
have for that development to be able to
allow the pedestrians
to get from the site to
the co-op but they don't need that
crossing point
to get to the schools which in our we
feel
is the severe is gone
i hope that helps thank you for that
um
right i think that's that's informative
so we move on
to councillor gould
thank you uh madam chair i hope uh
i'm audible to uh cassidy bourne
and others as you as you say i'm
speaking from
inside our town hall any place i can get
to with a decent
uh connection at the moment um as is
being said we have to consider the
application
before us uh not what might happen
in in in the future uh
the issue for me turns on
this um potential conflict with the
with the neighborhood plan uh but i'm
not sure
uh having read the report listened to
uh the the officers particularly mr
isabel
and uh and heard what's being said
that uh that conflict is sufficient
for uh to prevent us uh approving
this application on the application
itself
this is clearly greatly improved
on on the previous one and
uh i think there's a lot to commend it
in terms of the the issue with the
neighborhood plans is in terms of the
the numbers provided for and and
the plan itself acknowledges that
the there may be a need for uh
further development uh and clearly there
is
a substantial gulf between
the numbers provided for in the plan and
those talked about
in the emerging joint local plan
now whatever is allocated within that
plan itself
i think as mr isbell spoke about the
numbers that
underpin that plan and we we all know we
would
think that those numbers are certainly
aren't going to get
any smaller so there is a need to
to to to accommodate those those numbers
i think if the provisions of the
uh mppf uh 2019
uh which is given on set out on page 41
of the report
lay down the conditions for the um
presumption paragraph 11d to apply
one that the plan is less than two years
old
secondly that the neighbourhood plan
contains policies and allocations to
meet the identified housing requirement
now such is the gulf as i say between
what's
being looked at in terms of the joint
local plan and what's provided for the
neighborhood plan
that i would be surprised if that
need is met now i'm i'm thinking
uh by way of comparison with our
experience and neighborhood plan here in
i
and we've seen on the table it was put
up that i was
um the emerging joint local plan talked
about
uh an allocation of 541 i think
for i well actually i's neighborhood
plan
uh provides for over uh 700
houses so it exceeds the expected
jlp by some 35 percent
uh it's been possible to do that because
the sites
uh exist and there's been public support
uh throughout for that and that public
support
was uh very much to the fore when
uh a public inquiry appeal at a public
inquiry
for uh an uh an application for a site
that wasn't in the plan uh was rejected
by by the inspector
for all the very good highways uh
heritage impact and environmental
landscape impact
the one thing that actually uh
led to the refusal of the appeal was
the level of the allocation that
the uh that the neighborhood plan had
made
so because the level of the allocation
was right
in terms of delivery numbers actually
all those other policies in the
neighborhood plan
the neighborhood plan intact uh is able
to be
uh is able to be implemented um
and uh you know that in people's minds
reinforce
the absolute need to get the numbers
right in the plan
i i find a lot to commend this
uh this application i shall listen to
what others say
thank you thank you that was really
helpful to listen
uh to the neighborhood planned situation
thank you for that
um councillor hadingham would you like
to comment on the
application in our debate now please
um thank you and um and i like um
councillor casten and councillor gould
also find a lot to commend with this um
application
there are a lot of benefits with this
newer um
with this new one and um and and
unfortunately or i hate going against um
neighborhood plans but if they haven't
allocated you know the right amount of
numbers
it's um it's not going to look good for
them and um and we have to sort of
give the you know likes been said that
give the weight to what it's due
and what is um in line with them are jlp
and what is not
so i'm i'm i'm sort of torn at the
moment but anyway i'm going to listen to
what everyone else has to say
thank you thank you councillor hathaway
councillor hicks you've been very
patient thank you very much indeed i
know you wanted to say something earlier
thank you
thank you um can i just um just ask well
i'll run through my thoughts and then
i'd like to ask
uh mr israel some questions if i may so
yeah
so clearly the neighborhood plan
includes allocations that aren't
sufficient to accommodate the housing
need in our
draft jlp so that's been clearly spelt
out
we know the site now it's well defined
it sits within the newly expanded stowe
upland or on the edge of it
it definitely has good connections uh
and i
i'm not particularly concerned about the
questions that others have raised about
being sustainable or not and it has uh
facilities uh in the sense that to have
that
new co-op which has expanded from when
it was just a petrol small
petrol station many years ago has grown
so it's a great asset to the community
to have that on your doorstep
um so all those i see um
you know as as positive reasons or
reasons that we need to take on board
towards supporting the application um
but i am still
worried about this crossing so when i
look on the recommendation
on page 115 of the papers about the
grampian condition
i've got a couple of questions um can we
uh uh ask to change
the condition or is it is it wholly
wrong
that actually no building starts
at all until the crossing is installed
and the reason i ask that is we're
already talking about it being dangerous
in the area
and we've already heard about they've
been uh the local members said there
have been concerns and
you know there have been accidents and
it is a dangerous area already so
could we condition that's actually built
before even work starts
or could we defer this until that
is concluded we guarantee that it will
be built out because
that to me is really quite a critical
thing and i'm quite nervous about it
being so
up in the air i know i know uh sam has
said with 30 years experience she
thinks it will be but it's thing is
we're basing it on a
on a we think it will be and i like to
make decisions on it will be
uh and i'm just wondering is any way
around that so if mr isabelle could
answer that
uh thank you for your questions
counselor hicks i i was on the same page
myself about those very two questions so
um
if mr isabel could um perhaps allude to
something which might give comfort to
members as we move forward in the debate
uh thank you chairman so this is an
outline application
and we've talked about no occupation
until a controlled crossing has been
installed um
so what may also be appropriate
is to bring forward the scheme design of
that so that that comes in
uh not later than the reserve matters so
that this is all coming in
uh early on to to um
to defer this until such times you had
the scheme on the table i think would
probably be
would would be something that would give
robert generic i think probably quite a
a a degree of difficulty i think that
would not be reasonable
and and then the question of whether you
could not start building this until you
had a
a crossing in place planning is supposed
to deal with the harm
the harm arguably here that we're
dealing with is the access to the
crossing also access to the co-op
and the danger for occupants of the new
development uh
and i think the reality is that
occupation is
that critical factor that gives rise to
the harm that you need to meet now
at the moment you have this set within
uh a planning condition uh arguably
um you could put this within the section
106
to require the timetabling of this and
it's its delivery to be
effectively unchallengeable for five
years because that's the way
uh you can approach section 106 so at
the moment a grampian condition will
will do the job um but it is open to the
the council to um seek to impose
a requirement and to timetable that
within uh
the planning obligation the section 106.
i think it would be
i think it would probably be
unreasonable to expect there to be
no building because the building is the
thing that will ultimately pay for this
and we're
we're dealing with uh uh an applicant
who will be
selling this site on to others and that
is their business model and i think
there are those who are interested in it
um i don't know if that helps counselor
hicks officially at this point
well does it how how can i how can we
as a committee or how can i when it
comes to my vote
make this a more solid and confirmed
matter because
council ebern has raised the point and
count and
the council welcomes ward members that
this is up in the air and still unknown
and
and my worry is they build out the
estate
uh and they still haven't got this
sorted and then they come back to us and
say sorry we can't do it
so you know how can we get confidence
that this will
absolutely be built out so that's what i
need
i i think probably we are talking about
putting this into the section 106 rather
than leaving as a condition chairman may
i come back to you on that question and
yeah and put my put me down over here
and think about that for a little bit
and then revert
please thank you very much thank you um
thank you for that um councillor
humphreys
i'm sure thank you uh interesting debate
actually
um although this is a new proposal for
outline permission
all the reasons for the refusal of that
previous
application although not relevant really
they seem to have been addressed and
arguably to a more than um
satisfactory level in my opinion i'm the
developer he's been cooperative in
all of these matters and additional
pledges of money to support the highway
safety aspects
i think must be welcomed and will lead
to safety improvements throughout
especially 115 junction and the crossing
benefiting not just stolen syrupland and
its residents but the wider community
that live around that area and i have to
thank councillor welling uh
for his persistence really on the
crossing but i do share councillor
hicks's
um concerns over that crossing and the
viability of it will it happen
and i think it's absolutely right to get
more clarity on that
prior to this going forward and i'll be
interested to
hear mr isabelle's uh come back on that
now that grumpy condition
um i think it works it might give us
enough to be honest with you and as
mr israel said unless people can move
into the buildings they're probably not
going to sell them
but they have to be built to produce the
money this is a
sort of a chicken and egg situation
really so it's difficult
there is a need under our glp although
it's emerging
for more housing that's been clearly
identified that's pretty much agreed by
the whole of mid-suffolk district
council
and that's why we voted on our jlp um so
that is coming forward
page 113 sort of um sums a lot of this
up actually instead of mr isabel's
comments
when it talks about let's get my glasses
on i won't read it all
uh it talks about uh accepting that as
per paragraph
11d at the mppf the policies most
important for determining the
application
are out of date meaning presumption in
favor of sustainable development
which this is is applicable and the
decision should be made against utility
balance it then goes on about the tilted
balance but summarizes there are no
specific policies
the mppf which direct for refusal rather
the application complies
with the policies of the framework taken
as a whole and that's an important point
that actually it is in accordance with
the mppf and it is sustainable and i
think it's a fairly good plan
on the round um mainly because the
additional landscaping i think satisfies
a lot of the problems
the natural and wide buffers they've got
to be welcomed
and the protection of the meadow i think
that's a really important addition
it's excellent the highways improvements
that have been talked about they're
beneficial to everybody
yeah it's all good um as far as i can
see uh and they're welcomed
and as far as i'm concerned um they're
clear as day
so represent the um the considerations
or the
the upsets and the deliberations of the
residents and the parish council
previously
when it was uh when it's refused even
though it was a separate
um proposal um
i think all in all the the changes have
been put into this
are refreshing they should be welcomed
and we should take them for what they
are
there's been a lot of talk about cycle
routes about highway safety a lot of
distraction talk going on actually
and let's get to the root of this the
route is that actually we've got a
proposal in front of us
for outline planning permission and it
satisfies pretty much all of the mppf
even though some of the policies that uh
we were referring to before
are out of date and it does have some
conflict with the neighbourhood plan
and there is no real reason for refusal
on this um
the one one fight the b1115 we need to
consider that as well this isn't part of
the proposal that's a road that joins
stowe upland to stone market
and all that is important that we get
cycle routes and we make the roads safe
i couldn't see any evidence of any cycle
accidents along that road and again i
think it's a slight distraction from the
proposal in front of us
um so therefore as a user of that road
regularly for cycling
i see no issue with it it's pretty safe
i've never had an issue but i might be
the only one who knows
the bus timings um we're in the new
world people don't do 95 anymore
sorry if you think we do but we don't we
work all sorts of ships
and also in this modern world most
people choose
because they're allowed to choose cars
so the bus timings there are buses
they're not everybody's liking
the timings aren't everybody's liking
but let's not get away from the main
proposal of this
that's in front of us which is about the
development itself
it is sustainable and it's fine um
certainly in the sort of round and i
will listen to the rest of the debate
um i found nothing here there are some
slight concerns
but nothing major to say look stop um
so i'll listen to the rest of the bait
and make my mind up as we go along
thank you thank you for that councillor
humphreys and i believe sam i think
you've got some details regarding any
cycle accidents could you come back that
councillor humphreys asked about that
please
yes thank you chair um i've looked at
the transport
assessment for this application and the
previous application
and the uh one where that won an appeal
their bloor site
all of them the accidents show that it
was from driver error
rather than um let me just uh take sam
off my head
so with this timing if we put it
we need sam to talk so phil
switch off thank you sam yeah um it is
showing that it's through
all the accidents are through driver
error rather than does not mention
cyclists i'm afraid as to say i couldn't
get into
thank you as i thought thank you thank
you for your question on that councillor
humphreys
councillor mansell can we have your
views please uh thank you
chair um i i i share
a lot of the things that other people
have already said
and i i do actually think that developer
has made a pretty good attempt
to work with the planning department to
try to mitigate the issues that
were involved in the refusal of the
previous uh application
um but i do like others um
have a bit of a trouble with this
proposed pedestrian crossing
uh as in within my ward there was
highways
work that was needed to enable
development
which has caused no end of trouble
because it wasn't
actually um finalized before the
building started and i think they're now
trying to sell houses and it's still not
really
uh dealt with so i do have grave
concerns
about this uncertainty over the
pedestrian crossing
um and i i'm not quite sure what the
answer is
but at the moment unless we can have a
lot more certainty
um i i can't at all be comfortable
uh with this application um in terms of
some of the other changes which perhaps
haven't been mentioned yet now
this this application site is a smaller
area for development because we've got
the increased buffer zones
uh people have mentioned the housing
density but in actual fact
i think in increasing the housing
density may not be a bad thing
because it may mean that we get more
smaller homes rather than huge four and
five bedrooms executive homes so
that might actually be better if we have
uh more homes in a smaller area
um uh my notes are a bit all over the
place um uh and i also think that the
protection for threads meadow is is a
is a great benefit because at the moment
it has no protection whatsoever
um so if if that can be a protected site
within starplan that is a very good
thing
with regards the 50 000 pounds
proposed to improve uh the junction of
the b treble 1
5 and the a whatever it is um
i think now in our post-covered world
perhaps we need to
re-assess the priorities about what that
money is spent on
because we should be encouraging more
people to use sustainable modes of
transport rather than make everything
car-centric um and i i
and i i do actually consider that this
site
is in a sustainable location personally
i think cycling across um thorny green
is a delightful road to cycle on
so i was quite surprised that the ward
members said it was terrible and there
were so many
instances they had to call out the
police because
little has been mentioned about the fact
that there is going to be a cycle access
out onto
gipping road and you can cycle across
thorny green to join the
bike path that then leads down into
stone market and it is
1.8 kilometers to the station
uh and it's actually downhill uh which
is a good thing on your way to work
so i think it is a sustainable location
but
my biggest concerns are the the
pedestrian crossing
and the conflict with the neighborhood
plan now much has been said about the
allocations in the neighborhood plan but
let's not forget that at the time
stow upland uh made their neighborhood
plan and it was adopted by mid suffolk
those housing numbers were acceptable
it's only subsequently
in this draft neighborhood plan and
there seems to be quite a lot
of information that is not in the public
domain about the way
the way that that joint local plan is
heading
uh and i and i so i i i'm a bit
concerned about these
these uh uh behind doors discussions
about which sites going to be allocated
and which sites aren't
uh because i think uh if there are
alternative
sites which may be assessed to be better
that are going to be in the joint local
plan and this one isn't
then that that to me does put a bit of a
different spin on it um
so i'm not quite sure which way to go
because i do think it's just it's
sustainable i think there is a viable
cycle route to stone market station
but i have concerns about the certainty
over the pedestrian crossing
uh and the fact that it conflicts with
the neighborhood plan
and what sort of message that is giving
to the public
why are people bothering to spend hours
and hours and hours
making a neighborhood plan if it doesn't
actually mean anything
so i i'm struggling a bit
right thank you for that counselor
mansell and before we move on i think mr
israel can advise us a little further on
grampian conditions that
councillor higgs brought up thank you
apologies chairman had me mike on and
they didn't have me mike on to apologize
so uh what what i'd suggest in the
circumstances chairman is
uh an amendment to uh clause e uh
of the section 106 provisions on page
115
leaving the existing provision in there
but adding in
uh some text which deals with this
question about uh delivery of the
um the crossing so um what i'd suggest
as a way of
getting the timetabling of this right is
to include an obligation that says not
later than the submission the reserve
matters a scheme to a standard which is
capable of passing highway safety audit
for the provision of a controlled
crossing on the a1120 in the vicinity of
the co-op
should be submitted to the lpa in
consultation with the local homeowner
authority
so at the time you get the reserve
matters or not
later than that you get a scheme
submitted which shows something which
appears to be capable of passing safety
audit that's obviously a separate
discretion to
to be exercised then go on to say the
scheme should include measures and
timetable for delivery of the crossing
such that is available for use prior to
the first occupation of the development
and lastly to say no development shall
con commence
until that scheme is approved so
effectively you have the timing of a
scheme which
should be eligible to pass safety audit
uh it
then goes through that process and
include with that scheme
timetabling to deliver this such that
links to the occupation of the
development
and then ultimately no development
starts until the scheme
has been uh approved and therefore will
be delivered
thank you chairman um and can i go back
to councillor hicks because he was the
one who brought
this up and yeah he did thank you i
think that's that yeah i mean for me
that i mean because they're multiple
layers of what you've just said
so actually that gives me confidence now
that this will be built out
at all no matter what so um with that
i'm
that takes away my biggest issue so i'll
be supporting the application
thank you and thank you for that so um
we now move on
uh to uh councillor matheson please your
views
thank you chad yeah i i did um i
was looking for quite a long time for
for something along the lines of what mr
isabel's
just um put forward with with the
with the reserve matters as an actual
scheme that that's
that is can be d well a design really
a design that's capable of being a part
past
or has been gone through an audit really
is is good yes
however and i think the the improved
detail that's been offered this time
doesn't um shouldn't take us away from
the
um the principle
and you know this is an outline
application we should be looking mainly
at the principle
and i think it's very disappointing to
see
such a huge effort um
made to to actually overturn the
neighborhood plan
i think that's a misplaced effort and um
it's disappointing and i think on some
of the
the assessment detail um
really we we're being pushed much too
hard in one direction
um the i think the point is we're
supposed to make on balanced decisions
and to say that it would be unreasonable
to to find
uh unacceptable harm where we did not do
so
in january um i don't i don't
like that we we have repeatedly over the
years been advised
not to throw um the kitchen thing in
when we're writing
reasons for refusal so um
we will be weighing more things
to reach a decision then we will put in
a real reason for refusal if that is
what happens in any case so
i think i think some of that some of
that in the assessment
which went rather strongly in the other
direction
was not i i didn't like reading that i'm
afraid
so if we turn to the to the actual
principle decision
the the difficulty the conflict the
tension that as
mr isabelle's described it um between
the neighborhood plan and the housing
numbers
now we're told housing need
and i think that if you actually look a
little bit that need
we find firstly that the needs been
calculated using
um a methodology provided by the
government which has somehow
had us wanting to build more houses than
the increased number of people that are
going to be living in the district
and public common sense struggles with
that
for sure and so i think that's
the numbers which are in any case at the
moment
not bolted down they are housing
evidence i think it was established that
they are published
housing evidence towards an emerging
joint local plan so i don't think we
should we
taking that and kicking the neighborhood
plan
out for that reason and i think the
the neighborhood plan will be reviewed
in time the joint local plan will be
adopted
and hopefully in the time scale we've
just agreed
council so i would say
what's the hurry and if we actually
override the neighborhood plan at the
moment
then really the harm the harm of
approving the application
the biggest harm is is actually
the damage to the neighborhood plan
process
across the district not not just here
but generally across the district that
all these
parish councils and people are working
on on them at the moment
and what will they think when they when
they see us
overturning it it's bad enough when when
an
inspector overturns it but when we
overturn it ourselves without even
it going to appeal that that's very
very difficult for me to swallow and i
really can't support this as it
is thank you for that counselor we've
been looking at your screen all the time
so i don't know where your microphone
your
camera has been so um very interesting
um can we move on um to
[Music]
uh counselor melon if you would please
thank you
thank you chair i hope i'm appearing on
the screen yes
yes so uh i'll try to be brief um
there is much to commend this
application in terms of what it delivers
for the community
the uh community ownership
of the meadow sounds good the
delivery of various sort of
infrastructure improvements in terms of
the crossing my children all through
them went to scotland and
you know ran the gauntlet of traffic to
get across to get their lunch
uh at the petrol station so a crossing
there is
would be um a fantastic thing and i i
wholeheartedly endorse
councillor hicks's idea of bringing that
forward in the process
um so for me the thing turns on the
whole
conflict with the neighborhood plan um
and that what the the neighborhood have
expressed
is that desire not to push the envelope
of
stowe upland further out into the
countryside
um and to sort of put a boundary on it
there
um if there's a conflict um
it's a numbers one about the fact that
the numbers in the neighborhood plan
don't quite add up to what we think they
should do at present to deliver
what we at the mid suffolk want to
deliver
but it seems to me fairly clear from
what the ward members said that further
sites will come forward
to deliver those numbers in due course
and those sites will be
at the stone market end of still upland
i.e for me the more sustainable end
of the development closer to stone
market
closer to the shops and those sort of
things
this development would push more traffic
onto church road and what i was seeking
for when i
talked to councillor william earlier was
to understand
not what the design is of the junction
there but what is the reality and the
reality is that that junction
from the bloor homes site is already
choked and people are turning left to go
through the countryside because they
can't turn right
now if we allow this one on that adds
further traffic onto that junction
it pushes stop and further into the
countryside
when we should be pushing it back
towards the town
so in my mind this site is
too far into the countryside uh
it's away from most of the
facilities that people will need i
totally understand that people will
choose to
use a car but that has consequences
it would be far better if we had
development
around the b115 at the lower end of stop
and closer to the a14 and i believe
that's what will come forward in time
so i find it very difficult to support
this application at the moment
thank you for that um we now move on to
uh councillor mayer please
thank you chair the neighborhood plan is
is the crux of this matter for me um
and i'm not going to drag it out but i
think this is not actually a new issue
in that the strategic
um planning policy team highlighted
before the plan was adopted the startled
neighborhood plan
potentially has not got enough for
residential allocation so
it's not a new point of friction
for me personally the balance where do i
see it i think i
find in favor of the draft joint local
plan
moving on we talk about implementing and
respecting the neighborhood plan the
meadow is
is very important and i speak from
experience in one of my villages
where a farmer's field that for decades
had been used by the community was
plowed up
it caused real consternation so if the
neighborhood plan expresses a wish to
control
the meadow then this application gives
that and we shouldn't
underestimate the benefit to the
community of the council
controlling the meadow
the crossing i think that is
critical but i do take issue
with um mr isabel
i don't think that crossing is needed
once the houses are occupied
when we look at the number of school
kids they're going to be crossing that
road
i sit in my um one of my rooms upstairs
and i watch the trucks
going through my little village to to
walsham to a building site there
you know that crossing is going to be
needed to protect the people that are
already living there and not just those
that are going to move into the new um
potentially the new site
so if possible i'd agree with councillor
hicks
we need to bring that forward and giving
the investment that the
developers will put into this site i
think it's not unreasonable to expect
them to spend
money upfront to safeguard the village
people and put in
that crossing as early as possible but
it does need to be protected
without the crossing i would be voting
against this
but as it stands and taking into account
the neighborhood plan all aspects of
that i see a lot of benefits
um i see a lot of positives and actually
i'd like to applaud the developers
so often when we reject plans
the developers rush off find themselves
a very fancy legal team
and take it to appeal well all credit
for this bunch they didn't what did they
do they listened to the
issues they respected those and they
developed
a much better um proposal and so i
i think that should go to them but as it
stands
i marginally but i am happy to support
um and we'll be voting for this plan
thank you for your comments thank you
councillor muller thank you chair
um i'm not going to repeat what all my
colleagues have said but i do actually
agree with
much as what's been said today i do
think the crux of the matter in my in my
personal opinion is the actual crossing
and i'm satisfied with the uh
amendment that mr isabel is is
recommending
and i am actually minded to support this
application that's all i need to say
thank you
thank you very much for that councillor
norris
councillor norris
yes you're there go for it
oh sorry my system is very slow i don't
know whether i'm moving right we can
hear you you go for it
oh we can't hear you now what have you
done where have you gone
can you can you put your mic on it is
difficult in this heat isn't it
we can't hear you now can you unmute
your mic
please counselor norris
councillor norris count um rob can you
help counselor norris
mike we can't hear you
absolutely so i'd turn my other
microphone on so the public can hear as
well i think it might just be a bit of
delay so if we just wait no there we are
go for it keep going okay no there's
very much a delay um yes i find there
are lots of positives about this revised
uh
application but um without going over
all of the points that have already been
raised
a lot of the issues that i have have
already been mentioned
um control crossing yes this is
uh somewhat now tempered by
the amendment that philip isbell
has suggested uh i'm pleased to see the
possibility of
improvements to the 1120v treble 1
5 junction i
do have concerns regarding the conflict
between
the jlp and the
local neighborhood plan and i'm
also concerned about the issue that's
been mentioned about the additional
traffic
on the law homes junction
so i am rather undecided and i will
listen to the rest of the
debate thank you thank you for that
councillors councillor stringer
thank you chair um thank you for the
opportunity to speak
uh i actually find this one not that
difficult
and it comes from uh 20 odd years of
experience
of actually several planning
applications in this precise area
so first of all i share the frustrations
of the village uh
about the safety and the traffic issues
at this point
and i think we owe it to this village to
get this application
right and i firmly believe that the
application we've got here
at face value looks absolutely right and
bang on
but it's only when you scratch under the
surface you realize actually this is a
completely unsustainable development for
many reasons
first of all i want to tackle the issue
about the cycle routes
all of the cycle routes i've been shown
today are conditioned
on another planning application the
approval of the sick form center
at stow upland high school so those
cycle routes are going to be happening
if they haven't already happened anyway
can i also just go back to first
principles first principles in the mppf
you do not use your most productive land
for housing development
this land is grade two the best grade in
mid-suffolk
so if you want to grow food in the
future please don't build on fields like
these
uh i also wanted to go over the history
of some of this
i happen to be on the planning committee
when we approved the two houses
on the other side of the road with the
two new driveways
the driveway is not shown in the plan of
the proposed crossing
the problem with those are if you put a
central island in the people can't turn
left coming out of their homes
they just run over the island and they
also don't have enough time to see what
the signals are doing and know if
there's anyone on the crossing
if you then start to move the crossing
to the east you start moving it up the
hill towards the junction
and it's too close to that junction and
one of the reasons
we weren't able to condition such a
crossing when we did the
revamp petrol station and when we built
the houses was because there was no
safe scheme that had been audited by the
county council
in fact we were prevented in putting
that condition on
by the highways department because there
was no safe scheme
and to date there has been no drawing of
any safe scheme
in this area so as far as i'm concerned
if you think you've cracked the cr the
crossing issue i think that's hugely
wishful thinking
i will not approve anything until i see
a proper audited plan of this
and the reason i say that is one of
deliverability
we have similar schemes across
mid-suffolk i've got a scheme just up
here
that the planning committee have
approved twice and
twice it's got to bring about some
highways benefits they can't do it
safely
and the houses have lapsed and they
haven't been delivered
one of the major principles of the mppf
is the housing is deliverable
and if the crossing is not deliverable
and you haven't seen a plan to show that
it will
then the houses won't be delivered you
then approved an undeliverable site
against the mppf can i also just
tackle something about the neighborhood
plan the primary document in looking at
this planning application
is under the mppf the maid neighborhood
plan
it is the only plan that's gone through
any inspection
the draft joint local plan has not been
through any such inspection
so the raising of that as well the
neighborhood plans got to meet a target
in the jlp
frankly for me that has not been tested
by an inspector
and should be which is why i won't be
supporting this because what i think
will happen if we approve this
we will deliver less houses in the
future because the plans for stow upland
uh as as they put forward into the jlp
was to deliver houses on the other side
of the village
closer to the town of stone market which
means they can deliver more houses there
more sustainably and more safely if we
approve this one
they'll have to revisit those plans and
put less houses in the more sustainable
area
so i will be personally voting against
this proposal thank you chair
thank you for that counsellor um we now
move on to council of war boys please
okay right um
i find myself echoing in some respect
council mellon and councillor stringer's
words um first of all i think there's a
certain
i'm concerned that there's a linkage
between the
developing a feasible safe crossing
at the cooperative food and developing
the junction
on the b1115 and there's been
substantial development already in
stockton
stockton high school is now over a
thousand students
who and i think suffolk county council
and highways
have a duty of care to provide a safe
crossing point to
to the to the co-op it's it's it
shouldn't there shouldn't be that
linkage between that
and this development of 80 houses
um now at president stokeland
is uh surrounded by green fields
it's uh in the middle of the countryside
i think the joint local plan has
identified the potential sites between
stockland and stone market so you're
going to see
a stow market stockman conurbation
a sort of a suburban
spread if you like a stone market
i think it's i've looked through the the
read through the neighborhood plan i
think it's a
very well produced document
uh it has it is they have been flexible
they have responded to
the need for more housing they perhaps
they haven't met
this target of 752
houses but they have moved a long way
towards it
i think it they have identified the
importance
of this northern fringe to stow upland
this is the settlement boundary this is
where the countryside begins
this is great to
agricultural land it is our best and
most versatile landers
council stringer said it is perfectly
reasonable
to my mind to say that this is a point
beyond which
there should be no large scale
development
uh this isn't just to the advantage of
scotland but
anyone who travels through suffolk they
need to be sort of clear that
suffolk is an agricultural country
um sorry county
um so i i
i think a huge amount of work has been
put in by the developer
and the officers i think they have tried
very very hard to get the best deal
possible
uh for stockman out of this development
but i think the
the way which it overrides the
neighborhood plan
and the settlement boundary i think
that's a line beyond which
i don't think i can go so i i won't be
voting
in support of this application
thank you for that counselor boys well
it now comes to my turn
and um i've been listening to um
all the all the um
comments um
i'm not going to go over the whole thing
again and there are very many positives
here
one thing i would like to consider to
ask the
officer if we can ensure that the uh
planting we're all talking about
just the uh highways issues really
um but that the planting can be brought
forward at the beginning should members
be minded to approve it
um because i think that needs to be got
in place and place services mention that
too
and i think we need to get that buffer
in place um
i think with all the improvements i'm
content to vote in favor of it
so i think really that's me finished on
my comments
um yes councillor humphreys
councillor humphreys and councillor
castle councillor humphreys first please
melanche sorry i've had problems with
the buttons pressing the microphone on
um would you be happy for
a proposal at this stage given the fact
that you just summarized
i think so because everybody's had their
time to speak
and i think um particularly with the
item that uh councillor hicks brought up
which we did bring up a briefing and
um philip has eloquently given us
some confidence and comfort with that
added in do you want to hear that again
if you're
about to make a proposal i presume yeah
i've listened internally to the debate
and um
there's been some excellent points i
think raised by all the councillors and
the officers done really well to answer
all those questions pretty quickly and
um
it's been very good actually so so well
done all it's been a difficult
debate uh we've all got different
opinions but i'm of the opinion that
this
development is extremely sustainable and
satisfies many of the reasons for the
previous refusal
although it was a separate application
and it satisfies them well
i agree with councillor mayor that the
developers should be congratulated on
this occasion
for not running away and for actually
coming back and going you know what
i've heard you i've listened to you
here's my here's my solutions
and here's my mitigation i think that
they're really good it's very
sympathetic
in my opinion there are no planning
reasons why this can be refused
i think it's abundantly clear from the
from the document set
and therefore i propose approval
um however subject to the condition that
was asked for by councillor hicks
and i think uh mr isabelle spoke about
i'd like that read out again prior to
going in absolutely and are you happy to
add in that we could um have the
planting brought forward before um you
know to make it very early which is what
was in place services document and
that's something
i think that would be a slight cramping
condition as well are you happy to add
that in that would be
something you could get going without i
see no harm in doing that
um as long as everyone's in agreement um
well that's you and
and also it's gonna soften the blow when
they're doing the development so
yeah i would add something in but again
mr israel firstly can you read out the
um
the condition that you applied which is
um what
counselor hicks spoke about and also um
consideration about planting
yeah please thank you thank you council
andrews
thank you chairman yes so um what i'm
suggesting is in addition to item e
on page 115 highway improvement
contribution
uh so the addition is not late in the
submission the reserve matters the
scheme to a standard which is capable of
passing highway safety audit for the
provision of a controlled crossing on
the a1120 in the vicinity of the co-op
she will be submitted to the lpa in
consultation with the local highway
authority
the scheme shall include measures and a
timetable for the delivery of the
crossing
such that it is available for use prior
to the first occupation of the
development
and no development shall commence until
the scheme is approved so that's e
can i suggest uh we have a landscaping
condition
a series of those which are talked about
in the conditions
but you have an obligation which relates
to landscape and open space maintenance
and management arrangements being agreed
that's item g
of your section 106. bearing in mind you
are interested in
advanced planting i would suggest that
we would include
g to include advert measures for
advanced planting in accordance with
place services advice chairman so that's
an amendment to g so landscape and open
space maintenance and management
landscaping
arrangements to be agreed to include
measures for advanced planting
as required by uh place services
and councillor humphreys are you happy
with that yeah manchester thank you i
think that that covers it really well
um and you know what it's not a big ask
is it so yeah i think that's that's a
great addition
yeah and then i've got councillor castin
had his hand up please
thank you very much yes i'd like to um
i'd like to second that proposal please
i'm very happy with the conditions
um i think we've had a really good
debate on this one
i am i think it's time to go through to
a vote
and um see how counselors are feeling
okay are we not allowed to come back and
comment
again after the motion has been posed
i haven't finished yet i was going to go
round again and ask for people to speak
to the motion
thank you councillor mansell i've got
that on my list
so we go round again to talk to the
motion
thank you council casting do you want to
say anything else
yes thank you very much yeah i'd just
like to say
yeah i'm i as you know i'm for
this proposal to approve this um in
front of me i can see
a um set of scales with a um
on one side you've got the issues with
the neighborhood and plan
yes these are important issues but on
the other hand
you've got the need for housing which
carries significant weight
we need these jobs more than ever at the
moment um
we need modern houses built to um good
standards
we need those in an area with links
and facilities the houses i like the
size of them i think
it's really important for us to be
building these
houses that are in
the more affordable well
they're they're easier ones for our
young people to buy
not free four-bedroom houses um that
will be very expensive
so yeah i won't go on too long because
we've got a lot to get through but um
yeah i'm i very much approve of the
this proposal and the conditions
attached to it
thank you very much councillor field
uh i quite like the conditions that um
councillor hicks proposed on the level
crossing on the level
there's the crossing pelican or whatever
um but i still find the conflict with
the uh
neighborhood plan uh really unacceptable
the allocations that the plan had in it
has in it
were the allocations appropriate when it
was written
we've been told it will be revised
and to me i think that really
rather swings the point there are
alternative
sustainable sites available in the
village and there's every intention of
bringing those forward so
i think i will be against thank you
councillor gould uh nothing more for me
uh i will uh be supporting this proposal
thank you um councillor hadingham
um thank you um i just want to say that
um
when people have suggested that that
there should be more
um development towards the stone market
most villages want to have a sort of
clear
buffer or demarcation between the town
and the village and so i think
clearly then you build that towards the
countryside not towards the town if you
want a clear buffer
rather than a sort of a conurbation of
amalgamation between sort of snow upland
and stone market
so i think they're building in the well
like i say the only other
if you want some sort of buffer is to go
towards the countryside so i'm veering
towards um
um supporting this thank you
thank you councillor councillor higgs
nothing further to add thank you
thank you um councillor mansell you
yeah i'm sorry it's just that it's just
that councillor kassadin has said we're
going to go to a vote and i thought oh i
i want to say something else don't worry
i've got my crib sheet here i know i'm
not bothered but um
no i i i was just going to say that that
i am a bit
still a bit concerned about the words of
the uh
amended uh section 106 condition
because if i've got it right it was
something about um
the scheme for the crossing which
appears to be capable of passing a
safety audit
uh can we not have it that it's already
passed a safety audit
because i i am i do have concerns after
what i've heard
that it will not actually be possible to
um on the table is what's on yeah i know
so i i'm not happy with that condition
it's not strong enough for me
and i listened to councillor casten
saying that we
that we need all these houses for all
these people who don't exist
um but as councillor stringer pointed
out
i think with this uncertainty over the
uh
crossing i'm not convinced that there is
a viability
for this development to to come forward
because if they can't deal with the
crossing
it may well be that we never have it and
it may put other applications
that are more preferred by the stockton
nobody have plan into jeopardy if this
is approved
and is undeliverable so at the moment
i'm sorry i can't be supporting this
application
thank you for your comments councillor
matheson
yeah i don't think the public will be
able to understand
why if we've got somewhere around 8 000
planning permissions
already approved but not yet built
why we want to add add one percent more
to that huge
number well i think excuse me this is a
simple problem
counselor matheson i think you're
banning a figure round that might not
quite be accurate so i think you need to
pass caution on that well
it might be 7 900 we'll see i think
um i think our planners will come up
with something a little bit more
realistic
carry on you were going to speak to the
motion but i think you need to be
careful what your what figures you're
busy
that is that is all all i wish to say
there is no hurry to approve
even more right okay thank you for your
comments
counselor melon no further comments from
each thank you chad
thank you for that councillor mayor no
comments
thank you thank you councillor muller no
further comments chair thank you
councillor norris
uh thank you yes i have still some
reservations
concerning the conflict with the
neighborhood plan additional traffic
at the bloor homes junction
and i believe more work needs to be done
on the potential highways issues
uh including this uh certainty regarding
or otherwise
of this controlled crossing uh so
i don't think i will be in a position to
actually
support this thank you okay thank you
for your comments councillor norris
councillor stringer
thank you chair um there was there was
comment made about uh well surely you
want to build into the open countryside
and not near the town you want to buffer
well actually that's for the locals to
decide and they have decided
and they've clearly put it in a plan and
we should not ignore that lightly
in fact the government says we shouldn't
ignore that lightly uh
those ones that want to build bill build
are saying do not
take their decisions lightly you should
give them the most weight within a
development plan
and here we are merrily throwing it
aside and we should not do that
we should also not lose our most
productive agricultural land we should
not lose that lightly
and and actually approving a development
here you are then only a couple of
fields away from gipping the next
village
so actually you know they've chosen
which one they want to be nearest to
they've said stone market we're now
saying gipping
i think they should decide so i i
personally think if you back this
proposal you're just putting another
nail in the coffin of neighborhood
plants in mid-south i'll be voting
against this proposal thank you chair
thank you for that thank you council of
war boys
well i agree all heartedly with council
stringer i think
in this context the neighborhood plan
carries enough weight
to establish that this is the
northernmost
um settlement boundary it's the limit of
of development for stoic
and they have they have supported
development towards stone market that
which is for the for 443 houses
uh and on sustainability counts that
would be
far far better i think that
i think we should respect the
neighborhood plan and i think we should
reject this proposal thank you for that
council of all boys
so our proposal and secondary robert
carmichael can you go through and ask
for people's votes please
cheer so i will now go to
the vote and i will ask if you could
please respond with for
against or abstain and myself mr depray
will
will confirm the vote after taking it so
councillor james carsten
four councillor john field
against councillor peter gould
four councillor kathy guthrie
four councillor lavina hattingham
four councillor matthew hicks
four councillor barry humphries
four councillor sarah mansell
against councillor john matherson
against councillor andrew mellon
against councillor richard mayer
four councillor dave muller
four
councilor mike norris engaged
counselor andrew stringer against
and council of all boys against
so chair and justice mr duprey i make
that eight votes to seven
in favor of the proposal
um thank you very much i agree eight
thank you for that so um thank you to
everybody for
um the lively debate on that um can we
just take
um would members be happy with a 10
minute break or do they need slightly
longer i think 10 minutes because we've
got quite a lot to get through and there
are
people waiting in the background for us
10 minute break i'm happy with 10
minutes thank you
thank you for that councillor norris
let's go for 10 minutes robert can you
time us please and just
bring us back in thank you
well good afternoon again and thank you
very much for your patience
um for those who've just joined us my
name is kathy guthrie and i'm the
referrals chairman today
um we have had a long debate um
already and one application
and because of the time and the heat but
the most important thing
is sam the highways expert from suffolk
county
council can't remain with us that it's
been decided that we will defer this
matter
robert can you give any more information
uh chairman if i if i can help phil yes
um yes um sam harvey has another
personal commitment
um and she'll be leaving us shortly my
instinct bearing in mind the subject
matter of the
the update on uh the thurston scheme is
that actually
there's so much of it is going to be
here on highways that actually you know
that would deprive members of
the opportunity to investigate the issue
properly and i think to proceed without
it
we would end up with another deferral
anyway um so my advice to you chairman
is that
we actually defer consideration of that
item to a forward date because i don't
think we're going to get through the
issues
once presentation's done yeah well i'm
i'm more concerned about
um the the fact we haven't got highways
with us
so um somebody's just put something
there i'm not sure what that is
oh sorry counselor it's harry richardson
here could i make it just a small
comment off the back of that
suggestion just thank you chair just um
speaking as the ward member i just want
to say like completely endorse what
mister is just said
i think highways is a crucial part of of
the reason why this application was
deferred initially back in january
so i think if we are to make a
determination out of the way i do think
we need significant highways input to
explain what's changed since then
so i think um leaving the match until we
do have highways here
is a very sensible idea yeah good okay
thank you very much indeed and so i
think all that remains for me is to
thank
everybody who have everybody has put
themselves out with various meetings
being cancelled holidays being amended
combine harvesters stopped all sorts of
things and
all of you that have entered into the
debate today
thank you and that's it if you'd all
like to
now leave the meeting thank you very
much the meeting is closed
thank you thank you thank you good
evening
you